you know how there's a type of jav and
this is only in jav but it's like
the creepy dude right like like you know
we we call we call it the ugly bastard i
think
it's bastard i've always wanted to know
what are the actors like in real life
because i've always wanted to know right
because it's like
like 50 year old men looking yeah yeah
and they're like and they purposely have
to like act
creepy right yeah just like we actually
need them
hello and welcome to another episode of
the trash taste podcast i am your host
for today gigguk and with me are my
usual co-hosts
the boys sea dog va and the anime man
we're the boys now i guess that's just
how it goes i mean
let's just keep it simple from now on
right no no more nicknames and today we
have a very special
guest with us we have uh kaho shibuya hi
i'm the girl here
we got the boys and the girls girl
you are our first female guest it's nice
to have a bit of a mix instead of just
having
it it's finally nice now that the only
female on this show isn't rhea
we actually have something nice to look
at now but uh why don't you introduce
yourself
right my name is shibuya as you
introduce me thank you
um oh where should i start ask
i started my career as an jb actress
which
is jb means japanese adult video
right
yeah before that i i was a newspaper
reporter after courage um
and then we did a little bit uh english
teaching
tutoring uh just teaching uh english for
kids like who were studying for toeic uh
that's kind of the job missing again
right i think only japanese people care
about toeic yeah yeah
or again like the english proficiency
test right yeah yeah oh
okay i don't know i had no idea what
that was yeah mostly in japan
yeah i mean we don't really have to dig
it right like we know we're proficient
hopefully if you ever go on like tinder
here i think you'll get people being
like hey
i need help with my toeic by the way you
look like you speak english
yeah i had no idea what the english
proficiency test was because i know
like japan have like the n1 n2 or
whatever that's
called efficiency in japan for sure
you're obviously not going to hear about
it because you don't need to learn
english
right but i heard that you got like an
amazing toeic score right what's your
torah score
highest is 9.90 990 which is kind of
weird like you let's see
yeah it's not actually 10 points but i
take
that score yeah so you've got a perfect
expectation
so when did you start learning english
then i guess it started from
high school i mean like we had english
school yeah like in airmen to school or
middle school but or we were
who people know me drop it i've noticed
yeah yeah like we don't know when to use
english
but then i got into wwe
really really yeah that's getting worse
oh my god
okay i was just
used to like naturally watching japanese
professional wrestling
because my dad was a physician for that
like japanese wrestling
federation or that organization so
it was just natural for me to watch
professional red things okay right
and yeah and then you got into it from
that
like they came to japan oh okay so they
had a tour in japan
that was actually the second time like
they took a tour i couldn't make it in
the first time
i think the first time they still had
rock i was like
oh my god that's going way back that's
going so far
one influencer in the world by the way
i guarantee there's like a group of like
really young people watching this all
like
the rock isn't he the actor yeah
he wasn't back then yeah yeah yeah
exactly i just imagine like
you younger just going around can you
smell what they're wrong that's like
your first like sentence
oh my god i remember in high school when
uh or in like
uh middle school when people would just
say that and just immediately fart
it's just
yeah yeah there's like can you smell
what the rock is cooking and
it was just like it was just like a joke
and everyone started doing it it was so
[ __ ] annoying that's
hilarious joey's like damn i gotta write
that yeah
okay so wait so you got into wwf
at the time uh yes that stage i saw
triple h was actually the star the
champion
[Applause]
i'm not gonna mention that but yeah just
keep it a secret
i want to stay mysterious
so yeah trooper h just came out i was in
the front row but very close to front
row so i could just
feel actually his water splashing
wow wow so you were you were in the
splash zone yeah
wow you could smell what he was cooking
wait splashing water like sweat what oh
no he does this
i don't know if he's still doing it
right right like he just put water in
his mouth
when he comes out yeah yeah yeah i
remember as a kid i used to try and i
begged my parents to buy me like the
wrestling you know like
action figure seven yeah
yeah i never got into wrestling i mean
like
uh my uh my uncle was like a pretty big
fan my japanese uncle's like a pretty
big fan of the japanese wrestling side
yeah but i don't know i never like
really
said i know if i sit down and watch it
though i think i'd love it i mean it
just it just seems like anime
with real people yeah basically like the
the the only thing i know about
wrestling is from super eye patch wolf's
videos about wrestling that's pretty
much
my knowledge on wrestling yeah yeah no
it seems like something i could probably
get into if i
had the time to commit to it because it
seems like a lot of fun yeah
isn't it just like a basically just a
pantomime but in like
basically it's a stage performance right
yeah it's like a theatrical thing
exactly
kind of like a final fight with a
drummer yeah
you like what you enjoy hacker like
doing a lot of stuff
yeah yeah exactly yeah because that's
like because it's all coordinated right
yeah it's
yeah yeah as far as i know and i think
they're very famous moments where are
they because i remember seeing him i
recommended like
top 10 ad libs in wrestling yeah
something i can't believe what was the
athlete i caught what it was it was like
someone meant to slam the table but he
slammed his face
and i was like oh [ __ ]
coming up next and watch mojo
so did you ever think about i think
there's gonna be a weird question but
did you ever think about
i want to be a wrestler or like did you
ever think about like going into that
side of things not really because yeah i
just wanted to like
get to know them but that's it like
maybe
become a physician like my dad or you
know maybe a translator i don't know
but so it's basically like us with anime
where we we saw anime we saw it's in
japanese so that was
our motivation to learn japanese for
anyone who did at that age
well we didn't want to go into the anime
industry we just wanted to talk about it
yeah exactly right yeah yeah i'm i don't
have a physical for pro wrestling
obviously
i'm like i don't know if you guys can
tell but i'm very short because
compared to these like huge i don't
think i'm that dude
i don't know how tall my audience think
i am because everyone assumes i'm really
short
the first comment i always get is man
you're a lot taller than i thought
the opposite thing in real life people
like i thought you were taller yeah i'm
like what
[ __ ] it might just be like the white man
an asian man
right like it's like oh he's asian so he
must be short oh he's white so he must
be tall
i remember when we had our akiba video
and everyone the
all the comments were i can't believe
god's taller than connor
my image is shattered for some reason
i'm like six foot ten
like i don't know why people think that
like just a normal guy
leave me alone stop bullying me so wait
so you got into
wwf yeah right
you don't really wanna learn language
from them you know
like you know i don't know i'd be
fantastic if i met a japanese person who
spoke like a wwe
i don't know i try not to say it i just
realized like everyone everything they
say is so like anti-japanese culture
it's so in your face and that's so
opposite although to be fair if a
japanese person came up to me and said
do you smell what the rock is cooking
i'd be like dude you are awesome
i love you then
you got me you got me all right okay so
i remember
because i i interviewed you for my
channel i think it was
this year last year right yeah yeah at
ax we did an interview together and i
got to know like a lot about your
backstory and whatnot we'll obviously
get more into that in this episode
yeah but uh as you were saying at the
beginning you
before you came into the jab world you
went to uh like journalism right like
with the baseball stuff yes
so i want to know now now that i know
that you were into wwf before that
how did it go from wwf to baseball
journalism
it's just it i was in a company so like
i didn't have a choice like
oh my god decide where i should go right
baseball is like what japanese people
watch the most
japanese people okay so would you have
liked to have done like what wrestling
journalism
yes yeah so that was like so that's that
was your aim
okay that's pretty interesting
but now you get to talk about wwe yeah
exactly did you get any say in doing
baseball like do you like baseball
uh i had no idea like i mean like i
didn't know anything about the ruth
you know well i don't like it you're
already a great reporter great
protecting the space like i i i
i grew up in you know i've been
to guard school girls only school from
elementary school
for like 12 years i was like in like
gender one gender
yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm the same yeah
joey went to an old boys school i went
to an old boys school
in six years yeah for six years so
middle school and high school
yeah yeah oh yeah because elementary as
well right yeah i didn't know they had
girls only elementary schools is that a
thing in the uk uh i don't know because
pay a lot i think
yeah it's it's like private school it's
yeah because you've got to pay a premium
i think if you want your girls to be in
all girls not surrounded by those dirty
boys
disgusting boys stay away from boys
you say that as you're with three boys
okay so i guess yeah so from my
understanding because you were in a girl
school your entire time right
i mean they still play baseball though
in girls school or i guess it's softball
yeah
some only a few right yeah so i had no
idea how
the sports
because baseball is pretty popular in
japan isn't it yes it is yeah
i think is it the most popular sport or
is that soccer i
just say it might be baseball right yeah
i have no idea i think the top three
sports from what i remember here is
baseball soccer and summer
oh the top three most popular right
obviously they play other sports
like wrestling for example yeah but uh
yeah i think i think baseball is
probably the most popular right
they have 143 games at least a year
jesus yeah more than right yeah because
i i know a lot of like
american teams scout out japanese
baseball players oh yeah i don't want to
talk out my ass cause i literally know
nothing about baseball i've been to one
baseball game um in america
and basically the only way i could
really have fun was just to get
belligerently drunk
and that's what everyone else seemed to
be doing isn't it really slow baseball
like it's at least in america right
there's like an ad break after like
every throw
yeah yeah i don't know i don't know
exaggerating that's what it feels like
watching
us i don't know it just feels like one
of those really boring sports to watch
i'm going to piss off a lot of baseball
fans now also okay well if we're pissing
off people
dude american football is so [ __ ]
boring and
they actually do have an ad every time
anything happens
okay okay it's so annoying okay let's
okay
i'm i can understand american football
yeah american football when it's in
when it's in motion it's like one of the
most exciting sports it just has
too many breaks but sports like baseball
cricket goals
i never watched baseball i never watched
soccer i always used to watch the
cricket right
and if you thought going to a baseball
game was slow go to a cricket game well
that's like a four day thing and
well no no no no no no no no no no no no
that's all i guess no i didn't okay
you're talking about the test cricket
which is like one game is like
five days long okay right they also have
there's three different types i can't
believe i'm going to talk about
it's very educational so basically
has three different types of games
there's the test cricket which is
the really long one that most people
associate cricket with right yeah yeah
five days
no one goes to watch those right yeah i
don't know i mean they do but like you
have to be retired right and have
literally nothing else to do
because it's five days and then there's
the
what they call the one day international
or the rodi which is
it only goes for one day this man knows
his [ __ ] yeah
i mean it's a cricket man and then
there's a shorter version which is
called the 2020
which usually only goes for about three
hours
so it's like it's only three hours it's
speed running qriket
and i and going to watch the 2020 qriket
the short one is really exciting because
they have a limited number of balls
right so they have no choice but to try
and smack the ball
as many times as they want so it's way
more interesting whereas test cricket
they have five days so they can take
their time
and and is it true that after the five
days you can still come out with no
winner yeah there's draw
yeah there's drawers as well yeah the
best analogy i heard from that is like
imagine having sex for four days and
then in the end nobody comes
that's test qriket that's what it feels
like
but like the test cricket at least in
australia at least in my family
we would put on the test cricket just
like we put it on the tv and then just
have it in the background
and do other stuff around the house so
like every now and then we were coming
to the living room being like oh who's
winnie
like i wouldn't sit in front of the tv
for five days being like
oh my god this is so exciting most of
the time
nothing's happening right edge of your
seat stuff yeah yeah
when i was younger and uh my whole
family likes qriket but i don't like it
and i've made that very clear to them
that i didn't like qriket right
so 13th i'm 13 years old and it's
christmas right
guess what like the main gift they got
me was quick about a ticket to watch the
uh ashes
the ashes the ashes and i was like mum i
didn't ask for this i asked for yu-gi-oh
cards
it clearly says i know there's no santa
mom come on i'm not putting up with this
act anymore this is [ __ ]
and i'm pretty sure my my parents bought
me it just so that my dad could like be
like well if you don't want it
i like i'm just calling out my parents
did you get you your cards
no i didn't i didn't i just had to like
forfeit my main gift which is a ticket
to the ashes
yeah if i were you i would have like
gone and sold that ticket to like a
friend
one of my 13 year old friends was going
to go to the ashes alone yeah come on
go to the go to the middle of [ __ ]
nowhere in england watch a game for five
days oh my god
yeah okay so you eventually though had
to get a better understanding of
baseball right because there was
essentially your job i had to like um
did i score
a board a scorecard oh okay okay yeah
scorebook is what we call in japanese
kind of like a baseball crafts manager
kind of thing
it sounds like you're very interested
so how long did you do that for about a
year as a
baseball baseball reporter i also did
editing okay okay
yeah oh on that note can i just oh yeah
we
completely forgot that we had gifts what
about you know my boring career
no no no no no we want to hear about it
yeah yeah yeah
yeah so this is summer time in japan
like
which is summer gift oh but it's got
pikachu on it
yes pikachu and evie on it cute where
where'd you get that from
uh pokemon center i go to the pokemon
center quite often but i've never seen
anything like this let's let's open it
yeah they have collaboration with this
oh it says yeah there's a play online
should we open it yeah do you want to
open it up yeah sure yeah
so is this like a traditional japanese
gift where you give in the
summer time then okay especially for
business partners like
oh okay you want to set gap too yeah
yeah yeah i i still
i still don't understand the intricacies
of japanese business etiquette
because there is an etiquette behind
japanese businesses um
do you want to join the show off on
camera yeah it's uh which is like uh
like a biscuit right yeah yeah it's
really nice
see this it's probably very famous in
japan it's from a gumball
prefecture oh that looks good
yeah well we won't we won't eat it on
this episode because we don't want to
like
eating ourselves yeah we don't want an
asmr episode but thank you
thank you thank you so much oh thank you
happy birthday
i had no idea i had no idea it was just
as
at the time of filming it was just
connor's birthday last weekend
yeah happy birthday what'd you get
connor what'd you get it's a pokemon
sweets it says is it a cake yeah some
sort like pokemon cake i mean i don't
want to take it all out and ruin it but
it's very cute i'll put that away for
now but thank you so much man you're
much nicer than our previous guest he
just took all of our beer
thanks chris love we love you chris we
love you
i'm going to ask something and uh you
know so i watched joey's video where
he interviewed you and i watched a ton
of videos that you were in on youtube
i can't say that you did because earlier
i was like yeah i was i was doing my
research to connor
about about about your career and he
just burst out laughing
you know how it is right i know so i i
wanted to ask because it must be
i don't know this is what i want to know
on joey's video all the comments
on every single video that you're in are
always the same it's like oh opens up
chrome tabs
yeah it's like oh how did you like not
you know look at your breasts or
whatever
like does that get annoying like when
you're just want to collaborate on like
a podcast like this person kind of you
know feel sorry for joey too because
no no no no no i also invited him to
join my
radio show you know when we post
and we can we share like we retreat yeah
there's at least one com at least
oh like is aki okay with it's like oh
maybe they're going to have a threesome
right
like they just think that you just like
cannot stop having sex yeah
it was a job not a lifestyle
yeah yeah exactly and b i was very
retired even
at that time yeah yeah i am now but but
even if you were still working in it
this assumption that you just you just i
got to make a porno i've got to [ __ ]
something and film it like
it's so strange i felt i felt bad for
you like yeah i didn't really care
because it's just my comments right
whatever but like
because like the whole point of my
interview with you was to get to know
you as a person right and obviously it's
a you know
of course it's inevitable that we're
going to cross that right
right
but like yeah like obviously it wasn't
every comment
it was a lot of comments but i saw a lot
of comments as well who are like oh you
know like i totally saw a different
light in her like you know yeah she's
actually a really nice person and like
that that was my whole aim right but of
course
the internet is always going to be the
engineer so i was just really
yeah but like i don't know i would be
really annoyed if i was you
if i if i went on to an interview of
some person or
anybody no i just appreciate this you
guys so much for bringing me out here
in spite of all those like future in the
other comments
no no i can see that no no we
want to bring this up to call out the
[ __ ] comments now because what's
gonna happen is right someone's gonna
immediately type this comment before
they watch the video they'll get 30
minutes in they're like oh [ __ ] i got to
delete that
and if you don't you're you're just
going to be casted as a clown in the
conversation
right at least be creative you know
that's all i want yeah yeah we don't we
don't need the same
five millionth incognito mode comment
yeah we're gonna see on
every video be a man don't use incognito
keep that [ __ ] in your history the
apartment in the other
like does it does it um because the
question i had
was you've had a very varied career in
terms of like everything you do now when
i read when i was reading up you you're
like a streamer you're a cosplayer
you're a writer you've done a lot of
things but how's your
career in the um japanese adult video
industry has that like
affected how people view you in when
you're doing other things
at all mia i mean i
appreciate people like started knowing
me
because of jv like i still keep the same
name because that's
the name like people know me
yeah i'm like i appreciate that for that
because of that experience i get to like
more like i get to speak more
yeah you get to have an interesting
conversation because of that experience
i don't want to be like just like
forever
people just forever see me as jb yeah
yeah like even though like
i'm retired but it just doesn't matter
yeah yeah yeah yeah because i think uh
uh mia khalifa recently uh she had like
i think was it like a breakdown on
twitter
or on instagram or something i remember
reading up about it where she actually
regrets
working in porn because of how it just
completely
dehumanized her and affected her in a
way that she can never recover
so i guess for you have you have you
ever thought that you've regretted
that career at all the reason i'm
right now i'm not making an only fan
account or like i'm not doing anything
because i want to redeem myself not as a
jv actually as a past or
current yeah because i want to have a
second career like i want to show
people that you don't have to keep
taking off your clothes just because you
did it once
yeah yeah that's why like i'm encouraged
to do this like
yeah just being myself and that's like
that's how why i have like so much
respect for you because
anybody else would change their name you
know yeah after jav right because
they think they're like oh no like
people if they see that name
people are only going to remember me for
that thing yeah but the fact that you
didn't just goes to show that like
no i can i can grow out of this right
like i'm confident enough in myself that
i'll be able to sell myself as a person
yeah and not just like the person that
once used to do porn right like that's
i don't know that's that's that's really
cool that's big dick energy right now
from the boys embrace my past like i'm
not a shame adobe i'm not necessarily
proud of it like i've never
been proud of what i do like as a
newspaper reporter or
as a teacher like if you're i mean some
actress actresses say like oh like we're
helping
japan to have a low crime rate low sex
crime rate or something you know
but maybe it's true but i guess if
you're doing any kind of jobs like
you're helping somebody
in a way yeah yeah you don't really have
to be proud of it so yeah of course of
course yeah you're working so
yeah so i'm not necessarily proud of it
but i am proud of it that i'm
kind of growing out of it yeah yeah it
was a stepping stone for me i'm not
doing the same thing
like i do wear a sexy run trees or maybe
sexy cosplay you know but i'm not
showing anything more
yeah yeah yeah right i'm not you know
making a
secret account like to show more people
can subscribe and you look at me
you don't have enough i don't do that
you just did it again
yeah exactly so i'm just very curious
about
how you transitioned from being a
baseball journalist to working in the
jfe industry i mean that that's that's
kind of that's quite a career change
that's a bit of a jump
i think that's a standard promotion as
far as i remember i mean i mean i i i
changed from working at the bbc
to doing youtube i thought that was a
big career shift but that's nothing
compared to you i think
yeah i mean i've always loved writing
but like
i still do uh actually my physical book
is coming out your memoirs right
no necessary memory is about i think as
a reporter like a report of jv industry
everything about me it's not necessarily
exposed but
you can look and actually learn how much
i made during
this year oh okay i'm going to put out
all the lasagna paper you've had
paper definitely oh wow wow yeah
nobody can explode that much like it but
it's about me so i guess it's okay
that was a flawless transition to an ad
by the way
and what's happening behind the scenes
that sounds like a netflix documentary
behind the mosaic
that's such a good title good title for
because i think i watched joey's video
yesterday before we uh did this and i
think i think he asked something similar
but uh
i think we really want to know like how
did you like did you know someone that
was in the industry was like a
craigslist ad that you were like oh
porn actress needed like well how did
you like find your way in actually
i tried to have an interesting part-time
job
because i was like became
a teacher from a reporter i got more
free time
so i have a decent schedule like right
at the reporter like
it's like 24 7. yeah but as a
teacher like you have classes and that's
it so right okay i'm gonna have an
interesting first-time job because you
were that teacher
you were that
oh
so you started out doing photo shoots
first or was it well yeah like it was a
gradual because like
it comes out soon then maybe people your
friend's going to find out
soon oh so will you
like so so how did you even get the
offer to do photo shoots so
i was just looking for interesting
part-time jobs because my friend
actually told me
who was working at this pr company the
gaming pr company yeah
yes and she said i have this
personal job where i just jump in it's
nothing sexual
don't expect no no just when your friend
says i have this jaw
like it's like oh god outside
yeah yeah they got a mixer and we said
goku
in japanese right oh yeah and sometimes
they don't happen of course like i fill
in and i just pretend i'm one of them
right right she doesn't know anyone yeah
at the party
but like she just pretend like she's one
of them
a friend of them right so to explain
what a mixer is it's kind of like a
kind of like a group dating session but
not really kind of things like group
speed dating yeah yeah yeah oh wow weird
yeah
it's really strange yeah it's basically
just like it's like three
three guys usually it's like three guys
three girls right right even numbers
oh i
the girls just like chat up all the boys
see which one's good the boys chat up
all the girls see which ones i'm too
competitive and then they just
and then they're just like okay i'm
gonna take her i'm gonna take him i'm
gonna take her kind of thing
yeah yeah it's really weird i've never
done it
i don't know i've never done it either
that sounds like a lot of pressure it's
like something you would do
yeah i know no i couldn't do that
because i think i'd be like what do you
mean all three if you didn't pick me
what are you joking i'm joking by the
way going to introduce you to my friends
kind of thing
but improved not just singer i'm not i'm
i
[ __ ] i must sound like dennis from like
sonny and phil and everyone else's mind
it's just a social gathering to you it's
like
how do i gamify this how do i win you've
lost
you've lost i need to win this it's like
bro chill connor we're just trying to
chat like chelsea
turn everything into the olympics like
i'm like that guy who's like oh it's a
competition
oh okay game on yeah
oh my god okay so you did that job no
like uh my friend did that job i thought
you were probably interesting you know
pretending to be someone else
right right so i'm going to do something
more interesting
and actually what did you do on purpose
to one-up your friend
you're like turning it into a
competition oh my god i always want
something to write about
okay that makes sense yeah out of my
experience not like
trying to like i don't know sneak into
somebody's room and try to get
information out of somebody but more
like i want to talk about myself so that
i don't really have to hurt anyone yeah
so yeah uh there was a
part-time job called trying out
well in japanese it was called
adult goods monitor adults
yeah okay i don't know if you guys use
the same monitor it's just a testing
adult goods oh oh so called
monitor in japanese so you were like a
game tester before adult toys basically
no i applied for that job but then yeah
hey those companies who say like we're
looking for girls
for people for adult good monitor right
these companies are always
jv management company but they tried to
lure them in
oh that was like the fishing hook
if you're interested in that then maybe
you get more money
and then you're like oh sounds good i
was like i'm gonna
i don't think i'll get higher like i
wasn't that young
you know many jb actually sell
themselves that's 18 or 19.
but they're actually like yeah not
underage
20 but they sell themselves as like
young
young children of course so i was like
like maybe it could be interesting like
i should just
see how many offers i'm gonna get right
there
and then i got offers like decent
offering
right then it was just it couldn't get
out anymore
and then it just opened the floodgates
and then you were in and then it's like
a rage shadow legend sponsorship they
just they throw too much money at you
man
lately things are more legal and okay
you know but
during this afternoon it was more
sketchy definitely
okay right yeah they were like that's
really interesting actually just
i didn't realize that they like hired
people like that because it's
yeah because i've always wondered like
how like even in like the us as well
it's like yeah how did they do it like
i'm sure in the u.s it's probably like a
craigslist but i guess in japan it's not
really
like that because i don't see that i
don't imagine like flipping through like
a like a
you know a part-time job and being like
oh i don't think it's like a craigslist
i think you've got to get like you could
have done a ton of tests done before you
can even do anything yeah yeah
i think yeah there's a lot of that yeah
there's always another way but
i wrote that everything in my back
secret camera in english
i don't really have to keep secret i
mean there are people called scout man
scouting right right so if you know
at least one scout and he's gonna lead
you you're one management company
okay it's not it's kind of like agencies
but we never work individually in japan
i guess in the state
there are more like free agents yeah
yeah right
so is it is it like kind of like a how
an idol agency works
because i i i saw that you were like in
a in a jv idol group as well
like what was that about i hated them
got to get some tea secrets agency was
like oh you're in an idol group now
not again you're happy right you're
doing something beside porn so that
you're happy right you're gonna
i hated that attitude too right here
right right yeah you should be grateful
that we put you in something you hate
but i never asked you i'm not her idol
yeah what was that like because i don't
know anything about it so like what what
was that about like what did you have to
do was that i just
sing a cover song it wasn't even an
original song right right how many of
you were there
at some point it became more than 15 and
it
got
too many oh my god because i was i was
imagining like three or four yeah i
think
idol groups here are like more we need
more
because at the time akb48 was huge yeah
yeah yeah
more and more like wait so if we get 49
it's
[Laughter]
that would be such an amazing
conversation starter right it's like
dude my favorite idol group
maybe tky 69 tokyo
for 69 percent
so wait how long did you have to do that
for uh only
for a couple months i guess because i
started being busy
i became like a three-year-old as an
extras like
sometimes some actually say of course
like like in the u.s like you are
contracted to do only
with uh what was the name of the company
i forgot
like brazos oh yeah yeah
sometimes like you're contracted but i
got free from the contract so like i
could just shoot as
many as i want okay yeah because i
remember
in the interview i think i asked like at
the peak of your career
how often were you doing it and i think
you said you were doing a shoot like
every two days
yeah or something right that was
exhausting at some time like three days
in a row
three days wow it's like i think you
said like 15
likes like fifteen yeah
becoming fun when it became a routine
yeah
oh okay like i've learned all the
different situations
like i was a milf at some point
why do you want to suddenly become dio
or somebody you know
how does that look how do you watch jojo
and like i want to
i want to jack after this right now i
mean
it's like it's like a deodorant right
that's like if dio was like
hella horny
there's fan art where they like draw dio
and jonathan as like the 16th
the 16th chapel like artwork like the
way he's like
the god like oh no yeah yeah yeah
it's like yes yes um
what i want to know is like how cause if
someone was like connor do you want to
do porn and i was like yeah sure
how do you adjust your mindset to being
like all right okay i gotta
do this like were you just like oh yeah
sure okay
you just did it in the beginning i was
just curious like my curiosity was
overflowing so i yeah
i'm so excited but in the beginning i
have to play a role of like very
modest very shy like the innocent girl
yeah
like i only had sex with a guy a couple
times you know kind of thing
right right right that wasn't me
by the way so i couldn't say anything
like i could just
just be that kudurai girl i shouldn't
say any
virgo words oh okay right right like i
don't know how to respond like
maybe can i just say it's good or i
could i just i shouldn't want more
but i should just be recipients just
have to act like the inexperienced one
right yeah like that's always a thing
like i've noticed that like if there are
any new jov actresses that come onto the
scene
yeah that's almost always the first one
that they do yeah
and i think you were saying as well like
the first couple of ones are like the
highest pain right
for some reason i don't know why you
think that the more you do the more you
get paid yeah yeah
but it's the opposite in the jv industry
the upset yeah unless like you start
doing something more
like you know the back door or
so every time you do something new it's
like it's like paid more yeah oh okay
cause like the first time i see that
first time is always the best time
for them i have a question you said you
were in different scenarios and acted
different characters do you have a
script or do you have to like
ad-lib everything because we have a
script rarely
we have to outrip must be so annoying
having a script you're like
i just want to do it let me let me just
say [ __ ] i know what i'm doing
and especially for sex scene they don't
have escape at all in a script
it said a position and that's it right
right hey ratio 69
just eat it do not go longer than three
minutes 30 on doggy over cancelling the
shoe like 45
minutes in total right right right
and do you have to remember that or does
like the other actor have to remember uh
in the beginning because i was just
reciprocating
yeah i didn't have to do anything right
my director didn't want me to read the
script
because that could be too much acting
right i would have just loved if you
were just like in the position and they
just like busted out the scripture
all right what's what's my line again
chemo cheese
if you become like what they call
veteran right right
yeah experience yeah yeah yeah and you
have to be a
cougar or you have to be the aggressive
one
yeah so your role changed over time the
more you're in the industry though
i have to actually learn how to say
vulgar or like booger wrangling
yeah i actually took a note like how how
does peak
dirty like you know what the voldemort
notebook i wrote every single ornament
pier i could come up with like you know
to like describe like i i read a lot of
itchy manga
oh my god you actually use manga as your
source material
oh no isn't that so ironic that like
there's essentially like a loop going on
right it's like because i guarantee that
itchy manga artists
learn how to say this this is from jv
actresses
it's a recycle it's a good recycle
that's so funny you're just going green
whereas in like english porn if you're
just australian you're like that's it
that's the script
what's your nationality okay just use
that yeah just keep talking to him like
he's a close friend
i watched this uh us porn uh that was
what was that avengers it was about
avengers but in japanese it was called
hamenjas
i don't know the us title was if it was
a pun or something
but and the look was amazing they were
all
dressed in like how was how there's so
many horrifying ones yeah have you seen
the spongebob one
there's a spongebob it's horrifying
spongebob i'll show you later it looks
disgusting
there's also the pokemon one as well
and do you have a squirtle no it's uh
it's pikachu
i'm just curious it should have been
squirtled right but no it was
it was pikachu but like the girl was
pikachu horrible
oh they put this woman in like full
yellow body paint and it's disgusting
it's like okay there's misty right so
it's perfect that's the actress right
and like maybe ash and brock
no no she's called she's called fisti
and i think i think they changed the
[ __ ]
and ash's gash
but like well like you think that it's
misty right and it's like perfect
scenario and like i don't know maybe
pikachu watched from the summit no
they made the girl pikachu so it's brock
i'm sorry [ __ ] and dash we are not
getting ads on this app
hey follow us on patreon and they're
just like doing it with pikachu and i'm
just like
why it would have been fine if you just
did it with misty why did you have to do
it with a pokemon who's ever
seen a pikachu and going i want to [ __ ]
that oh gosh
there's a lot of the internet i i mean i
know you clearly haven't like seen the
furry community
no exactly right so like as a
professional as as a true professional
what is your opinion on like the western
porn industry compared to japan
when i watch the jamen just you know
yeah i don't know if that's addictive of
all porn in that
shock that how much they didn't do
script was
like they had a drama scene and that's
it like for sex they didn't do anything
like they didn't say anything
related to the story i don't think
westerners care
[Laughter]
this isn't professionalism be fair when
you've seen the way they act in some of
these pornos you're like no i really
don't want you to act i
i really don't yeah some of these actors
the bathtub one that's the one
shark there's a shark in the bathtub
have you not seen that
get out of the water one a shark get out
of the water sure there's a shark in the
water
there's no shark in the bathtub aren't
you glad you had a lifeguard here to
save you
have you seen that i've seen that yeah
like the jewels parody there's a guy in
the bathtub and a woman comes in
obviously looking very sexy and like
there's a shark in your bathtub and he's
like
no there is that's really dumb it's very
dumb everyone who's seen it is like oh
yeah
let's curse i'll show you later there's
so many memes of just like
bad porn acting that it's it's just
become like a joke
like there's there's like youtube
channels that are dedicated to just
uploading badly acting yeah
that's gonna look like old
[Laughter]
because like she's full body paint but
then they like spread and it's like oh
yeah oh no oh no no yeah it's pretty
nasty
uh courtesy of aki for showing me that
oh yeah
aki finds all the weird yeah she showed
me that one she also
she also showed me like there was a
spiderman one everything
yeah it was really bad there was also
barack obama one i remember
wait wait do they do do they do porn
parodies in japan we cannot do that i
mean
sometimes we try to do it but sometimes
we have to take it back
but there are some parodies ones because
of the like the fair use thing right
yeah because failures is not a thing so
much so that not even porn
can like parody it well like i've seen a
lot of like cosplay porn is that does
that count as parody or is that
like sometimes someone uh can't bring
the publishing company like saying
no don't do that they have to take back
something yeah yeah yeah they were okay
with fate because of faith
that that makes sense why all the
cosplayers i've seen is just fake
because face like
yeah we want the porn this is how this
is how people get into our game
got 30 right yeah exactly yeah i mean
that's what that's why there's so much
type moon
as well right because taiwan's just like
yes we want to give us all
we want to see another saber getting
[ __ ] so we can sell
more sabres saber having sex with saber
the class or the character sorry
i'm not a funny joke did you ever do
like any of that kind of stuff like did
you ever do cosplay stuff i wanna make
cosplay
uh i never got around to do the parody
yeah like but apparently if your actress
name is too strong like too well known
and that can just
i don't know uh that can be a nuisance
in a way
okay because because they don't see it
yeah they don't see the character they
they see these yeah that makes sense
yeah so like how did you
then decide to go after you retired how
did you decide to then go from that to
like cosplay stuff right i actually
loved cosplaying because i looked
totally different
yeah i think my first decent cosplay was
danwa
from far from here uh
from uh what was that was everything
which one was that what was the
character name daniela
joey doesn't know something i i don't
know either
fantasy i forgot i forgot okay describe
the anime what's what's the anime or
whatever
it's a game it's game oh it's a game i
mean
oh no bru ah drum roof fantasy
i mean at that time because i have to
shoot so many times
in a month but i didn't have time to
catch up on any anime
so maybe just one like i've been always
following like detective
conan yeah i know you're a massive fan
of protective conan like every time i
like see your instagram stories there's
usually something to do with detective
conan comes up
because like how many times have you
been to the uh the conan cafe
i tried to go there for the third time
this year
and then coronavirus hits ah okay i got
a refund too
that's good so what was like the
breaking point when you decided okay i
really want to get out of this industry
now i want to retire
because it became a routine like i want
something new in my life you know i want
to feel
bored of and i also want to change my
look
every single day you know what cosplay
is creating i
love manga and anime yeah like forever
like i think
maybe in the future more and more yeah i
want to try different cosplay i didn't
want to loot them too much
i i didn't really want when
they started like taking all the
cosplays like you know just that
it keeps the cosplay yeah yeah yeah
don't like put it off like
you're tuning in you do see some
cosplays on twitter that is like it's
this cosplay it's like two pieces of
material yeah like
what or it's not even that sometimes
it's like i'm cosplaying zero two from
darling in the frame that's just the
weird
and then nothing else i'm like great
cosplay great i mean that's
that's on point for the cosplay because
she is naked for like the first on the
first episode
that's literally how our character gets
introduced
yeah because i remember in the uh the
interview that we did when i was
uh talking about like the cosplay stuff
i remember you said something really
funny which is like
you your favorite characters in any show
is usually the characters that have
really small breasts and that
you feel sorry do you feel sad because
you can't cost i always go for frats
yeah yeah yeah so i think you were
saying like you cosplayed ram from
re-zero
right your favorite character was from
beatrice right yeah
another beatrice stan yes yeah yes
how do we find the three people on earth
the only three people who like be it's
just joy
no no he's he's a normal he's like i i
like red
i'm remo dying man
i loved wearing my rem cosplay as well i
love wearing female cosplays i feel like
people figure that out by now i don't
know why it's so freeing you know
like especially skirts skirts you get so
much movement
you know what i mean not that i want to
ever wear maximum efficiency but like
when i'm filming a video and i'm like
clowning around i'm like oh wait hold up
like you can actually like fully stretch
jeans are too constricting i feel the
breeze on my balls
[Laughter]
the reason i ever interacted with you is
because you posted your hestia cosplay
yeah
i was like and you passed it back you
posted your
google google [ __ ] like gone before
his hair gets out
that was mad jojo like vibes yeah yeah
photo
yeah yeah i'd love to get you on one of
the videos to judge my cosplay sometime
you're good yeah yeah yeah you're
getting a professional cosplay to jojo
yeah yeah yeah you can tell me how bad i
am i mean
they just clown on me for like 20
minutes yeah i've i've been on that show
i've been on his like series twice now
and it's uh
man i've never had to like bleach my
eyes like faster didn't you get high
absolutely got hives from one of the
cosplays yeah one of the one of the wigs
you bought
i guess was like really dirty because he
bought it from like a chinese wedding i
find the cheapest stuff i can find
it's like like a skin rash oh okay okay
it's called something else
like like i put it on in the video just
because i thought it was funny
and then the next day i just had hives
on my neck
and i'm just like coming up to your next
day yeah it was it was just like i was
like oh god what's this
and then i thought about i'm like how
did i get this it's like in a big bed
bugs
coming to my house and
or sometimes i just order on amazon if
good mo there are a lot of knockoffs
yeah yeah
even on amazon they're all i think we
wrote rerouted through like china
because yeah like it's like amazon japan
and then it's like three to four weeks
yeah this sounds a bit suspicious yeah a
lot of them are just awful
i remember my arm was like red yeah and
i was like oh yeah that is weird
that was strange i was like please throw
it away yeah
i i'd normally thermos them away if it's
just a small prop and i just
brought her on amazon because it's a
fast delivery so
do you keep all your cosplays uh
sometimes i sell
or i just give away at cons because i
go to animecon i don't want to carry all
the cosplay back to japan
yeah yeah that makes sense i'm curious
do you have any like
convention horror stories because we
have there i know yeah we have like
we have a lot so no one ever like tried
like step the boundary ever do anything
creepy to you at a convention
only at a doubt call like which i don't
go anywhere this is actually i wanted to
talk about because when i
was you know on youtube searching clips
they were a lot from adult cons
and people seem like overly like touchy
at adult cons and they're like it's okay
yeah yeah yeah and they're people just
like you know they go up to you and
immediately like put their arm around
you i hate it when people do that to me
what are you doing i don't know please
don't touch me yeah yeah and and like it
was just kind of
odd seeing that and then people were
like yeah make out with each other
and it's like yeah yeah like
how how is the like difference between
like is is does the is the adult con
basically as bad as it looks
it is um uh first of all like
in japan like or they'll sit down like
you can't even touch
an idol or like a parent like maybe a
handshake that's why we have handshaking
events
yeah but hound is the only area you get
to fear her
i'm never watching this here that's
where that's
yeah you're not even like we are not
westerners so like you're not even
supposed to like
put a hand on your shoulder or not even
on her hip yeah i guess in the west i'm
okay like you know
it's for taking photos together some
people are very gentle when i try to
like do
air hand here
yeah oh my god yeah i was just like i
was like internally dying
watching some of these clips so people
just go up to you and start like
touching
if someone
just smack him yeah yeah it's weird that
for some reason just because it's an
adult
convention that they can just you know
do what they want yeah
no they try to grab you like on easier
chest area or back area like
really yeah i know and [ __ ] do they ever
get into trouble with it or anything
like that or
do you have to like act like nothing
happens and you know sometimes i just
tell
someone like you know that guy just
touched me and some people like
ask nicely like it okay i touch your
breasts i guess
[Music]
it's like things that you ask about no
but then
they just try to be persistent because
the problem is right is that
they've calculated that it's a bit rude
to just do it but they haven't quite
done the rest they're like i
probably should shouldn't have actually
actually offered
excuses excuse excuse me milady would
you would it be
okay if i pertain a logic of like a
child being like
if i say please then maybe i can get the
cookie
so some people are persistent and they
won't take no answer they offer
tip like how much do i need to pay like
as a tip and i
just said it's like real life only yeah
some in the west like they take tips and
they
do that but i was like uh i don't have a
culture of tipping so
yeah yeah yeah yeah this episode of
trash taste is sponsored by expressvpn
expressvpn lets you access the internet
as if you're from a different country
like
joey's in a different shirt oh my god
and we're in a different position on the
table
[Laughter]
netflix has different shows and movies
available depending on where you are
with expressvpn you can unlock thousands
of new shows and movies from streaming
libraries around the globe
such as star trek's discovery on netflix
uk or brooklyn nine-nine on netflix
canada or even black adder on netflix uk
i like that show
i actually really do like that yeah
there might be hundreds of vpns out
there but let me tell you
expressvpn it hits difference
it's so fast that you can stream
everything in hd quality and not
notice any kind of buffering or lag
express vpn be fast
as [ __ ] boy and not only that expressvpn
is available on
every single device phone tablet pc
smart tv you name it expressvpn works
with many streaming services such as
netflix amazon prime bbc iplayer
youtube.com
and
actually have to use a vpn to watch
hentai i'm not joking not only that but
you can choose from almost 100 different
countries
that's a lot of countries
why was that funny it's so simple to use
just fire up the expressvpn app change
your location hit connect and then
refresh the page and show or movie you
want to watch will magically appear
i mean i think we all use expressvpn
right especially when watching anime
like sites like crunchyroll
kind of blocked in japan so the best way
is to just put on expressvpn
you get past that immediately exactly
and if you use our link today that's
expressvpn.com
trash taste you can get an extra three
free months of expressvpn for
free that's expressvpn.com trash taste
links down in the description below and
now
back to the video baby so obviously now
that we've asked about uh adult cons
and normal conventions how is it from
like japanese conventions like comic cat
to
american ones i guess sometimes scared
just watching some cosplayers
getting like overwhelmed by those camera
guys yeah
and they all take a low angle like
sometimes they are
too close like yeah i feel like they're
just taking
photos of pores like you know it just
works yeah right
there's no from i've seen some videos
and then it just seems like locusts
you know they they kind of like gather
around and they use conventions by the
way
and then they they have no respect for
like personal boundary a lot of the
times especially if someone's cosplaying
yeah
i think i saw a video of a college
player uh i think last comment was like
crying breaking down
yeah it was like it was the chinese
course right right yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah he's still taking
pictures underneath she's crying what is
wrong with you
i swear like just i don't know like
there are every now and then
i see like in u.s conventions as well
like some camera guys like trying
to use the camera i'm a cameraman excuse
me yeah yeah yeah
nowhere near the japanese yeah it's
definitely a mob memphis
like you know they all come together
yeah yeah yeah with it yeah it's like if
like one cockroach is like okay guys
it's safe and then everybody everybody
all right let's go in for the kill oh my
god
i've never been to japanese kamike or an
event in cosplay because you're not
allowed to cosplay outside in japan i
heard this oh okay
you actually need to change at the event
like the changing area so that's why
you know why uh yes they got some
complaints from neighbor
areas wow it's like i was just taking my
dog for a walk and this woman dressed up
in ram
just like rocked up and i i don't like
that character that's crazy how people
would complain about that yeah like
no good for the scenery or something
like that you go to like la during ax
and it's literally just like within like
a one kilometer
radius yeah that was a really funny
video last ax of like you know how in la
they started implementing the scooters
that are like kind of like
yeah yeah the ones that you can just
like pick up and go and then drop off
and it was like it was a video
of a guy just full on saitama from one
point
just cruising down the road
it was going so fast it was just really
funny because everyone was just like
did you did you see that i love that
about like
yeah yeah yeah just conventions right
just just seeing random cosplayers just
out and about
just saying just go walking into a
chick-fil-a and just seeing 80 percent
of people in cosplay is like some of the
funniest things
yeah there's obviously a lot of problems
with american conventions but like
i do think they are my favorite ones
because like it's such a fun atmosphere
and
most people understand that it's like
all right we're having a good time yeah
exactly
that's all just don't make things weird
yeah don't make things weird man if you
see each other in a denny's you know
yeah all right nice yeah
exactly i think especially recently
people have definitely gotten more aware
about checking each other and making
sure
yeah it's really they're not acting like
an [ __ ] anything like that because i
remember before about like
five ten years ago conventions just seem
to be operating on this
other level yeah i just yeah it was just
like
it was basically just right it's like
orgies yeah
it was just like an organized orgy
essentially it's like all right
everybody who is cosplaying
in inuyasha's stuff meet at the 10 p.m
in this hotel room that's basically just
all furry cons right now
just well organized with the butter mess
yeah
is that why like i see a lot of cosplay
isn't consent thing
yeah yeah people are touchy you know and
and i i know that there was what was
that thing a while back where people
would like kiss an anime they would
always run up to each other and jump
i i never went to conventions during the
glom phase when i saw videos of it i'm
like
people like full-on running into each
other yeah yeah yeah this is like man i
i like my personal boundaries a lot of
times you know i like my personal space
and i think with the general culture
shift to being you know a lot more
respectful
as it should be um i think that's just
kind of pushed in all
right yeah um because i think that the
big difference i heard about japanese
conventions because i haven't been to
comiket yet
but i've heard that people just go to
comiket literally to shop
it's it's it's it's literally you you
don't go for any events you don't go for
the convention itself it's literally you
buy what you need and then you [ __ ] off
yeah it's basically just like getting
heads first on
the latest doji from your favorite
artist or whatever and i'm like i
respect that
you know i want first dibs on it yeah
and you need to prepare a lot of coins
because they only take cash so yeah yeah
all right
i've never been either but i kind of i
don't want to go to summer comic yet
yeah that sounds like hell
i really i've always wanted to go to
winter comic but the problem is i'm
never in japan when winter
because i usually go to the go back to
australia for to go see my family for
christmas right but
i i think winter comic seems a lot more
fun i mean
summer just seems like some are here
just outside
it's just unbearable in japan in general
let alone you go into you have to get
used to it
sorry comes back like every single year
like i said oh it's japan
just yeah we live here
i'm just dying right now i'm so pale
like i
i was not made for anything above like
20 celsius right anything above 20 and
i'm like
ac so like i can't handle this this is
horrible i wanted to leave but obviously
we can't leave i mean i can handle the
heat because you know australia gets
really freaking hot this summer but like
where i'm from there's zero humidity and
so it's not the heat that kills me it's
the humidity it's
awful it's the fact that you walk
outside and it's and it feels like
you're standing in front of a heater
like
the entire thing you feel disgusted by
yourself yeah it's just like
i'm all sticky and everything's loose
it's like like a metal solid game it's
going to plan
every one of my movements to make sure
i'm always in cover you know i'm getting
to shade
right where's my box
like me and connor have the complete
opposite taste when it comes to weather
i love sunshine i love heat and con i
remember connor told me that his
favorite weather like patton is just
cloudy
yeah and and cold and i'm just like man
that sounds so dreary to me
that makes me so depressed because when
i wake up and i see a cloudy day i
remember i
i just imagine connor waking up with a
smile and just makes me feel bad worse
you know you know those days where all
you wanted to do was play video games
when you wake up and you were going to
play video games all day and it's
raining outside you're like yes
i understand yeah because you're like i
don't know i know no one's gonna ask me
it's a nice day go outside no i'm
playing video games mother
i just need sunshine when it's sometimes
when it's when it's sunny i just message
connor being like
in a beautiful day ain't it a beautiful
[ __ ] day today i'm there just like
sweating at my desk like i hate this
so much because in in the in the uk we
don't have ac it's like not a thing
because it normally it never used to get
hot enough for you
uh there's only like one or two days a
year right even though the one year that
we went to go visit you guys it was like
it was like the heat wave that
last of the month yeah it's been like
that a lot recently and so like
you've got these houses that are
designed to keep in heat yeah no ac
it's normally hotter inside your house
like 35 degrees it's it's hell yeah
so much i was like in tears every day
like i just can't do it i can't be here
anymore
how is the weather in thailand uh it's
it's kind of similar to what we have now
so it's like very hot very
humid um like all year round all year
round
like our homes are kind of designed for
it um like we have like very thin walls
and everything so it's designed to get
as much heat out as possible and there's
ac everywhere you go as well
so it's unfair you maxed the the thai
skill tree
i went down just the british i don't
even know what you get in the british
skill tree just poor taste in food
unfair this is just out of nowhere
christian but her
is milk in each country i mean like i've
been told by my friend in california
that
we're just talking about baskin robbins
because like we have always
each year they have pokemon
collaboration at baskin robbins right
so you know advice he was complaining
that
milk here or ice cream here is too heavy
because of the milk because
we use whole milk in california they
prefer
low bath or grass-fed milk
because i realized now when you told me
that the other day i was like wait
there is never any like semi-skinned or
like no fat milk options you can
order at starbucks but you can buy
low-fat milk though in supermarkets
i feel like i never see it the
supermarket near my house has
like skim milk low-fat milk uh like high
calcium milk stuff like that but i
always wondered i was like why does milk
taste so like
rich yeah i'm like this is weird like
that 100 percent
yes
i like i like the thick stuff because
like in in australia
he likes the thick stuff luke i like my
dummy thick milk all right
thick milk because like in australia as
well like we didn't really have a whole
it's like japan like we don't really
have a whole variety of milk
we have obviously we have the full cream
stuff and the the low-fat stuff
but it's not like america where it's
like would you like one percent two
percent
five percent ten percent it's like just
give me milk
i just want milk no because i
i haven't noticed much of a difference
because i don't i don't normally
i don't know i only have milk with my
coffee yeah so and i don't eat ice cream
too often either so i'm not a fan of
soft serve and that seems to be like the
most popular thing i really like soft
sauce
it's too milky i like if i want milk
i'll just drink milk
i want ice cream not ice cream that
tastes like milk well then just don't
get like the vanilla flavored stuff then
get like the weirder
soft serve yeah true like matcha matcha
yeah
it's pretty good but like just normal
macho like uh black sesame is really
good but vanilla's my favorite flavor of
ice cream so well then stop complaining
just eat your damn sauce okay in japan
as well right uh for some reason baskin
robbins is referred to as 31 wow
yeah what's up with that how did you who
made this it's because baskin robbins
i think might be like too difficult to
pronounce too long because i remember i
showed my my japanese cousin right
because she loves thirty-one ice creams
and i'm just like and when i heard her
first say that i was like 31 what's that
that must be like a japanese brand or
something
right that i don't know i'm like yeah
let's go to let's go to 31 ice cream and
i went
and it's a baskin robber yeah and i was
like yeah it's
it's it's just a [ __ ] basket and i'm
just like oh you mean baskin robbins
yeah we have that she's like
baskin what and i'm like it says it
right there in english
we just highlight the thirty one five
yeah yeah if anything it's
harder to see the 31 then you see the
background
because because the katakana is it just
says 31.
yeah but i'm like do you clearly not see
that on
either side of the three and the one it
says baskin robbins and she's like
oh my god i never saw that oh my god
it's like 31 is like five percent of the
logo
and you're just completely disregarding
the other 95 of the lot yeah it's
i don't know the japanese love to do
that though don't they they love to like
take western brands but completely
change the name of it
just to like fit their like way of
things like i i love how
uh in japan they don't call
mercedes-benz mercedes-benz
right they just call it bins right
yeah ice cream because you know what i
call a mercedes-benz in japan
yeah because they can't pronounce
mercedes because when i said that i was
like
they were like what oh what is ben's
like is it bins as an acronym what like
ben's are short for something and i'm
like
yeah it's mercedes-benz and that they
just they
their minds were just blown they were
like mercedes where did that come i want
to know the conversation where
mercedes-benz came up that feels like a
code word for like something i would
never say like
if i need to help mercedes-benz no no
because it was in the same conversation
of when i told my cousin that 31 is
called basketball
you're just speed running though yeah
yeah yeah so i had to like make sure
i was like okay what do you call
mercedes-benz because i guess i just saw
a mercedes benz you call a quarter
pounder with cheese
but lately we try to keep the same name
like ben and jerry's
kind of like you guys try to keep i mean
not you guys but you know like anime in
general
yeah just for kids but now like we have
the same
title we have the same ops and ending
songs
what do you think about like the other
way how like some
anime series completely changed the name
of the anime to fit like the american
way
right like what do you think about how
detective conan is
i understand that conor on the name
corner is just it means
it is isn't it why yeah why why it's
detective conan
because of the past it's too famous in
the state right
the the hostage oh conan oh yeah yeah
yeah the
the talk show host yeah thank you
detectives like uh
the character's name that schwarzenecker
played back in
the 90s oh
okay that's fair enough i mean at the
time i think it was coming around those
they were really big
detective conan o'brien i want to see
that now i want to see that sure where
he
we comes to change the name of a certain
child book
was it from germany uh
called in japan we called him tantang
yeah tantan is a boy who got a dog with
him
oh it's tinting oh yes but tintin sounds
oh my god
oh yeah that makes sense
so we got our own reasons yeah that's
like that's not like me and my japanese
friends used to like refer to the male
genitalia as just like as a joke because
we didn't want to say like the actual
thing in public someone probably would
just be like tinting
i'm curious because you've obviously
been anime and manga fan like your whole
life right
what do you think about i mean
especially recently in the west it's
gotten
really popular right and people like
everyone's like yeah i love
anime right yeah like what do you think
of i guess it getting bigger
and all that i'm happy at first i saw
some anime titles that western people
know must be only
well naruto and dragon ball and that's
it yeah yeah that's true like they
actually know
they actually get to watch the same
title at the same time yeah with english
up
yeah i mean to be fair a large majority
of anime fans
still only watch like naruto and dragons
huge
huge group yeah some people never get
out of that phase and then some people
yeah they now they just watch everything
yeah like me i guess
but before it was like yeah as you said
like before i think the general
like you know idea of a western anime
fan was like yeah i love naruto i love
dragon ball i love one piece
right and that was it what was like the
first us con you went to or your first
experience
was actually ax so the biggest one oh
okay wow
that's a that's a condo i don't even
think ax really counts as
it's not really representative of a lot
of other us conventions
because ax is ax is so big that
it's a whole different experience for
most others a lot of like japanese
industry people so yeah yeah yeah you
hear a lot of japanese
oh yeah yeah definitely have you ever
been to like the smaller con
yes they have so that was completely
different some clowns are
just fan based right yeah yeah yeah the
street people are the earth
very unorganized every single time i've
been
like a guest at a con something has gone
like horribly wrong with like my flight
my hotel really yeah yeah i think i've
been pretty lucky i've had like a few
cons where it was like
horrible yeah but a lot of the times
like especially the smaller cons i have
more fun at a smaller conference
yeah yeah if i get there yeah like one
time uh
this con booked me like like months in
advance and i
don't think they'd ever had an
international guest so i told them like
hey you should like book flights soon
because like
you're in the middle of nowhere in the
right right
i was like u.s need to book flights
because like they don't happen a lot
from the uk
and they didn't until like one week
before and then i had to go on like a 35
hour flight path 35 yeah well it should
have been a like a
14 at most right yeah that was the
cheapest friday
that was the cheapest one and i i asked
i asked them i was like how much was the
one
the other one that was like i think it
was like 12 hours right it's still long
yeah flight path and they were like oh
it was 150 bucks more and i'm like are
you kidding me
are you kidding me why did you agree to
this well i already signed the contract
before that because they said they were
going to buy the flights and i thought
they wouldn't do that to me
that's a real that's a real moment there
they wouldn't they wouldn't expect me to
turn up on my
flight and then immediately do a panel
within 30 minutes of arriving
and they did they expected me to do that
i've done that before so
and the worst part is they booked me a
hotel the night before that i missed
because of the 35 hour flight path and
i'm pretty sure
i'm pretty sure that hotel room cost
more than 150 dollars
so [ __ ] you that con
yeah every con is in in indiana now it's
just like sweating like
i've had a lot of the worst experiences
in that one car
of all states i don't know why i go
through a lot of cons in indiana for
some reason
it's i went to one in indiana which was
and that that one was actually quite fun
yeah i had a lot of fun with that but
that one
wasn't really well first it wasn't
really like an anime convention it was
more like a youtuber convention
so i think they were a lot more used to
getting all sorts of overseas guests
yeah yeah
was your agent doing all of that for you
when the cons or was it
you were you negotiating with them uh at
axe i was just an industry guest so i
was just
at a booth right other people but at a
smaller con i was a guest so
i got somebody from the car with me all
the time right
oh you got a handler yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah because i feel like because i spoke
english they were just like left me to
my own device and they were like [ __ ] it
just turn up
just i just we just expect you to be
here no i remember my first time
like being a proper guest at a
convention i think was like crunchyroll
expo
because i i had been guests before but i
remember that my first experience at
quantual expo they gave me a handler i
had no experience
like what i do with like like like he
would just follow me around
and i would just i would just feel so
awkward i would just be like
could you not i literally had to ask him
to like okay
can you just chill like i i'm not like
because i've heard a lot of horror
stories so
i get it now but back then it was my
first experience so i'm just like dude
can you just
can you just leave me alone i'm i'm all
good i don't need any help i'm just i'm
just walking around the contour but
every time i wanted to go to the
bathroom because like they had to follow
me and i'm sorry i have a small
brother sorry i want to go i'm going to
go again
yeah yeah so no i'm just very used to
being left my own devices as well
because i think it's a very british
thing as well you're like i don't want
someone helping me i can do it on my own
i mean like i think it's because i've
had like kind of my fair share of like
good
really good handlers and just really
useless handlers yeah
like i i'm a little bit better to like i
know how to use my handler now right
like i know
i know that's what i'm saying
i don't know i know how to maximize my
you know what i mean like like you know
i'm gonna min max this [ __ ]
joey turns up and he just gives him like
a like a [ __ ] 10
page survey he's like fill this out i
need to know where is my don perry on
when
the moment i land come on guys can i
speak to you i'm like this is [ __ ]
joey's had really good
experiences and i i feel like at least
half of my like
conventions that weren't like ax had
like something massive
it's really weird like you know you hear
a lot of like horror stories about ax
from a lot of different people i don't
think i've had like a
like a horrible experience at ax no i've
i think but i think it's also because
yeah but i think it's also because like
my schedule i purposely fill up my
schedule
yeah with as much [ __ ] to do so that i
don't leave enough room for error
right because like a lot of people are
just like i'm gonna space everything out
and then you know just give myself some
time in between each thing but i'm just
like no that's where the horror happens
right
it's the in-between part where you're
just kind of left on your own you're
like
well i guess i'll go to the convention
hall now and then horrible things happen
at the convention hall right
ax has always been like the super super
busy convention
it's everyone's always busy everyone's
always doing something like
what is your schedule like an ax is it i
was like signing
uh and they give in the first year
they gave me like a 30 minutes break
yeah cosplay so
i'll take off my week and i just kind of
shut myself just in a bathroom store i
would just
be myself i just want to take a rest why
are you gonna take a rest
i didn't want anyone to see me without a
wig you know okay
[Music]
and i took aspirin like every single oh
my god
i mean yeah i guess if you have like a
wig cap that's just like stretching your
head right
now like at some point i wanted like a
stronger mess or like
could you buy something yeah like in
in the state like i'm sure they got like
stronger rocks give me that give me that
because i've never cosplayed before um
and part of the reason is
it feels like at a convention wearing a
cosplay is just
a lot of effort and work to just to keep
it intact right
yeah i cosplayed once and that was at ax
and i cosplayed as gintoki from game
time and i chose gintoki because not
only because i like gin doki as a
character
but also because like his stuff is kind
of light right it's like it's a lot more
breathable it's not like i'm wearing
a full suit of armor right so i'm just
like okay it's really hot
this is a little bit breathable i didn't
take into account that i'd be wearing
a massive [ __ ] white wig
legitly is like like just a heating yeah
yeah and because this part got just so
hot yeah it completely just negated
like the free-flowing clothes that i was
wearing so i'm just like
i was i remember i was in the middle of
a signing i'm just like i'm sorry i
can't i just took it off
i'm sorry [ __ ] the hair man i can't do
it yourself yeah i was like i don't care
anymore i'm just gonna take it off it's
so hot in here yeah i see like some
people in eggs like
turning rocking up in like a full guts
armor or something i'm like
how the [ __ ] are you doing here it's
like 33 degrees celsius here right now
because if you just restrict all your
pores
you can't sweat it can't come out
you just can't come out right you're
impressive yeah that's why i wore a
virgin killer sweater at ax one time oh
yeah yeah i mean that's that's
breathable right yeah that's very
see what i mean is that why is that why
you like cosplaying as girls because
it's no no no
no it's it's dude i love skirts because
like you're
laughing because free dude i feel like i
can stretch like my full stretch you
know what i mean
but you didn't get stopped by a security
you're like no
in la it's normal like i i just swear
anything goes in la
yeah especially around i remember i ax i
got in the uber and it was the guy
and at the moment i sat in he was like
you're going to the la convention center
and i was like yep that's okay yeah and
then
they just know now it's just because we
just didn't say anything it was the most
awkward thing
i was just sitting there in the back
like all right
wait were you in like a skirt at that
time i was wearing the virgin killer
sweater
i was like crosstalk obviously it's a
taxi like oh my god
you just don't think
but i love like getting stopped by
people like can i take photos with you
another cosplayer that you know yeah
yeah of course
absolutely yeah i think the most popular
cosplay at aex was
prison school ah that was the
uh not the president the vice president
yes right yeah yeah yeah
i think that was last year and one of
the reasons
i bet it could because it wasn't the
year for prison school so
there weren't a lot of prison school
cosplays yeah right right
most of them were wearing tamamo or
characteristics yeah yeah yeah
as it always is i guess like i stood out
and some
father like asked me could you take a
photo with my son and his
his sound was like tiny yeah does did
his son know what the
series is the kid on the plane oh my god
[Music]
what are the pain to ax i mean i
normally use
we talked about this football like i
normally watch some shitty some
i always have like an anime uh folder on
my um
on my tablet never watch that always
watch shitty plane movies most of the
time
um but what's it what's your favorite
cosplay that you'd say
was like or is that like picking like
picking your children
top five cosplays my cosplay actually
next week i'm doing my favorite
character from final fantasy vii
i've done yoofy already for obvious
reasons you know
that's the most popular of course female
character right and if you got a chest
for that you can go for it yeah
of course but my favorite like my waifu
is yuffie like i just wanted to cosplay
you fee yeah yeah okay so i finally get
to do that
next week press uh cowboy bebop
oh george valentine's favorite favorite
that's the that's the resident evil
character
yeah what was like your very first
cosplay
oh it was my part of the grand theft
auto fantasy one right right right right
right
right
right
right
that was forks or
well could be super sonico
one of my like my own choice i don't
know
what was that oh i did mama go from
from uh from from the male visa guy ah
awesome did you write your mother do you
like your mother
not the attack that was such a terrible
show
yeah yeah we've talked about that i
think my favorite cosplay that you've
ever done was uh i think it was at ax
last year you did trishuna right oh yes
i did yeah
trish cosplay was really really good
yeah that was cool
i'm obsessed with jojo's we're all
awesome we all love georgia
speaking of jojo like the you have like
the jojo kimono
right that thing is so i ordered that in
osaka
i would have ordered that i don't care
how much it was i'd have paid like like
not even a question i'm gonna find that
on yahoo yeah
that's where i get most of my jojo
emerge from yeah i'm like using google
translate hoping i'm not clicking the
wrong things
connor's become that stamp collector but
just for jojo's yeah yeah
his grandkids are gonna be like what
what is all what is all this
yeah cause when i when i have a call
with my parents all my merch is behind
me like what are those toys
toys it's not a toy man this is this is
a one-sixth gyro zeppelin
two hundred dollars are you kidding me
you just like bust out the ocean
like you don't understand how pristine
this thing is right now
i i love getting deals for jojo's stuff
so much i also got jojo's smartphone
which i never use right jojo's
smartphone yes there is judges no not
like a smartphone skin like an actual
smartphone yeah
from docomo what what really why not
this exists
where can i get one yahoo that's
probably
there's so much jojo merch like you just
always like stuff blows my mind yeah i
spend way too much time looking for jojo
merch i know there's websites that are
dedicated to like tracking the release
of new jojo merch
really oh yeah and i kind of go because
they really so much all the time which
is
great you know being a fan i mean yeah
but sometimes there's stuff that's like
when would you ever use it like there
was there was one that was like
rohan kisube uh like tiny jigsaw puzzle
it was like it was like tiny though like
this and i was like
i mean like a four-piece jigsaw puzzle
what's the point like i'm never gonna be
able to like open this because i i'll be
scared to like
actually do it or like lose a piece
right yeah
it was something like 16. it was like
right it's barely a puzzle yeah there's
just other stuff like
i don't know i have no interest in clear
files but i think japanese yeah
i don't know why the clear files is the
default okay we're going to release
uh merchandise to do with this to do
this show let's just make clear files
it's because it's
so cheap to manufacture right it's like
the youtuber like first t-shirt that's a
reference
yeah they just put like xd you know it
just seems like the most tacky thing
ever and i i've never bought a clear
file but i've always been given them
as like a gift or something and i i
don't know what to do with them honestly
i have a bunch of clear files but i i've
kind of bought it's it's so ironic
i bought a file for my clear files
so it's like you know the tree defeats
the whole purpose you know there's a
file you know
it's like it's like a little bit they're
actually like they're actually like
custom made
clear file also not so fast files for
your clear files because people know
that no one actually uses the clear
files right and they just treat it as
like a piece of like art or whatever
yeah they don't want to use it but they
need some place to like easily access it
and i found one and they sell it in like
daiso and stuff like that oh
yeah if like 100 yen so i just bought
one don't they sell it daiso and so i
put all of my uh because i have a lot of
monogatari
uh series clear files right because if i
find something monogatari i'm gonna buy
it
so i just put all my monetary clear
files into my clear file file
to explain daiso is like the dollar
store here in japan where you can get
like
everything you didn't need every little
contraption you didn't know that you
needed until you go
until you go to the store anything you
need for your house you can find
anything yeah it's not that's so much
so how many files could you file in the
file
i think i think the one i bought i think
the one i bought you can put in like 20.
oh just looks like a lot you're like
right okay write this down yeah
20. yeah yeah but it's it's you know
it's nice like
right it's better than just having all
the clear files just scattered
everywhere yeah
it's in one spot just don't buy clear
files
and just please stop making them
companies we don't care we really don't
care
why is conor like being mean about a ten
dollar figure i'm like it takes up space
that space is for the expensive boys
yeah connor's trying to maximize this
i'm trying to make like the most
expensive jojo cabinet right
i mean you're doing a good job no i know
i'm collecting slowly you'll know jojo's
bar level but
no no that guy's been collecting like
deck yeah
a long time but uh yeah i think they
recently just started re-opening again
and uh man the collection there because
i went there for a video
and the collection there is nuts i i saw
so many figurines that i was like
wow i didn't know they made a figurine
of this character yeah
and and he had the uh he had that really
limited
jojo it was it was uh jotaro
jotaro with the swarovski one so it's
like full-on diamond encross to joe
dude and it's like i looked it up on
yahoo auctions it's like four thousand
dollars
that was pretty expensive and he just
had one on like a pedestal that sounds
amazing
i want to get it connor's about to spend
more money i'm like
wallet forgive me for what i'm about to
do i just i have to like not go on yahoo
auction because i will end up buying
something
that's why i never made an account on
yahoo auctions because i know i'm going
to spend so much money
uh yeah i did but i think it was a
little harder they didn't accept my
cards and stuff but
i was like nope you probably need a
japanese card right for me i do yeah
it's called there now
oh you do yeah i still don't i still
don't it's so hard to get a credit card
or a debit card here
it's i don't know what banks wants um
i don't know how you got accepted either
because i got rejected the first time
but like in the uk they just basically
just like give you a card they're like
oh yeah
they just you just you just press this
button
oh for a debit card no so like i won so
they rejected me for a credit card
uh which i only thought there was credit
cards and then i got a debit card but i
needed someone to like help me fill it
out because
they don't offer english ones like forms
so i was like well
i'm [ __ ] what do i do i want to access
my money because i was using my foreign
card for like the longest time
right yeah god damn i've got a question
for you though
what do you think about the whole new
simp movement that
just started in the western like the
western sphere
i'm like why do you guys feel when
somebody call you simp
like it's just even like out of it
if i say anything positive at all like
oh good job they'll be like wow you're a
simp connoisseur
but you just said a nice thing to a
woman i feel like the term sim has just
been used so much that nobody even knows
what the original meaning of the word
simp was sometimes
writing it's just like calling your name
kind of thing so yeah
my like mod uh on twitch like had to ban
the terms
i was gonna ask because i'm sure i never
saw the word simp in your chat
they are very they're protective of me
yeah it's because everyone in the chat
is
knows that they're just like we all know
why we're here
we're all sleeping for karma yeah yeah i
just like yeah
i just don't understand that term
anymore i mean you know the internet
does what the internet does best
and completely destroys the meaning of a
word the moment it goes means
because now it's like if you give a
female any attention
you're simping like we're probably
thinking you right now yeah just by
talking to you
you're going to
now that we just like blacklisted all
the incognito comments yeah
every comment now is just going to be
sim comments now obviously
yeah i don't know if it's just a joke
thing like we can laugh about it or like
you do feel like
uncomfortable actually like getting cold
oh i mean
i mean it's it's it's we're we're clowns
we're just part of the joke
i think the only people who are
uncomfortable with being called a simp
are actual sims
you know what i mean they're just like
how dare you call me out
yeah when the term is sick and good
t-h-i oh thick yeah
yeah yeah the chemotic i was like i saw
it was
mauritius maybe negative term for a
second because it's
sick you know so i saw
it's just another term for fat but if it
ends with a k
then it's malicious if it ends with a c
then it's complementary
it means your body first i didn't know
that
they were commenting like oh you're very
sick
i can see how that can just completely
slip out all right but like that's
again like that's another example right
the word thick
is used so much now that i see guys
calling
girls thick that aren't thick they're
not thick at all it's like
it's like oh have skin oh that's thick
i can't see your rib cage damn you're
thick it's like no
there's a difference between thick and
just being healthy
yeah right so it's like again it's like
cringe as well
the word queen oh i hate the word cringe
so much
like because at first again like cringe
actually meant something yeah
people didn't like it but then everybody
just started to be like oh that's cringe
that's cream that's crazy remember
people be like
uh whenever someone made a joke people
would be like oh that's pretty cringe
but i laughed and i'm just like
are you trying to compliment me i i
don't get it was that a compliment or an
insult
i literally don't know anything that's
like the biggest oxymoron
yeah it's crazy but i laughed on my say
that again
slowly so as a non-native speaker at
first i didn't know it was like a badass
thing you know kind of yeah it says ass
but it's a good term you know
yeah yeah if it's how fast it's not good
you just have to learn
that's yeah that's what i wanted to know
right it's like because you you do
stream
to an english speaking audience right
like how did you come to learn all of
like the english like internet terminals
right because it's
completely different to the japanese
right sometimes i ask my chat
like you know oh what does everybody say
that's a dangerous that's
i remember asking them i was playing a
game they're like oh yeah i was i wanted
to know the ping of the games like
what's the ping and they were like oh
it's all f4
and i just thought oh okay i closed the
game in a ranked match
i'm such an idiot sorry go ahead yeah
it's okay uh
because because like english isn't my
first language because sometimes like
people try to correct me even though
it's just obviously a typo
yeah yeah on twitter especially like you
can all edit
sweet so yeah even though it's just
it's just obviously typo it's just not i
saw i saw people were correcting your
english
i mean that was like laughter cause
sorry i'm like yeah i was in the cosplay
of laughter
character from you know iron blooded
orphans
and i was obviously in a cosplay because
i always like to make pants
or whenever i pause cosplay photos i
like to stay something that belongs to
the capture
yeah yeah yeah yeah so because like we
are having kobit 19 uh
why don't i just use the term laughter
is a good medicine
okay but you know i put the laughter as
a laughter you know
yeah yeah yeah and some people
just corrected me that's a long sparring
[ __ ]
but like on twitter there's always that
one [ __ ] because we make typos all
the time
and even if you delete your tweets like
immediately
they screenshot it they [ __ ] send it
to you like excuse me
i have this typo by giggup i know you're
trying to hide
like that is my absolute biggest pet
peeve
it's like two in the morning it's like
two in the morning and i'm like i'm just
gonna tweet something funny and then i
tweet it
like ten seconds later i realized
there's a typo yeah okay no one probably
saw that
deleter right and then maybe a couple of
minutes later i'd do it again but the
correct spelling
the first 10 comments is always hot i
saw that
joey exposed for making a typo joey
doesn't know how to spell and i'm just
like
[ __ ] like happens to everybody yeah
who are these people this is a call out
by the way
who are you what what do you what do you
get enjoyed what'd you get out of this
like why are you so
it's like were you like just waiting for
me to tweet to like
be like it's like chris hansen's like i
got him
did you think you were the only person
who got called out for typos english
okay it's not my first language
that's more of an argument of why we
should get it right yeah yeah because
it's
like right so we don't have an excuse
yeah at least you have the excuse that
it's not your first language yeah yeah
so maybe i should have quoted like
laughter
but i didn't make it obvious like i just
yeah i don't want to make it
yeah it's a joke like please laugh it's
really it's really it's it's that ironic
situation where like the person
correcting you thinks that you're more
intelligent about it when you made a
very intelligent joke that they just
don't understand right
if you're smart enough that you can just
guess like i'm obviously wearing golden
hair
you know green eyes which aren't
obviously mine
you can guess maybe it has something to
do with cosplay because i
know the sparing of that i know
that my english isn't impeccable but at
least i know the term impeccable
something about myself that's that's
more than most english people honestly
please people but i do like sometimes
make mistakes like some
words like sounds similar like obviously
obviously
testicles tentacles like i sometimes
think but they're both belong to hentai
actually every everyday words
yeah i make a good laugh so yeah yeah do
you ever get any toxicity online for
being in your position or anything like
that um for being an actress
i mean most cosplayers i know have a lot
of get a lot of toxicity you know let
alone
people who work to learn yeah jb yes
do you get a lot of dictionaries
appreciate it i mean i cruise my edm
only like it's only for my friends like
for yeah i think that's right anyway
that's a good idea mindset would yeah i
also closed my instagram dm but somehow
they always missed like there was some
yeah messages from
weird someone i guess someone was that
desperate for you to see that dick
the mainframe i need you to see my penis
i'm willing to go to jail
instagram had the bag i think
closing dms on twitter and instagram is
like step one of creating an account
yeah yeah yeah
like no one no girls appreciate
a dick pic i can just say that
no one well maybe like if we get to know
you better
here is my pick where's your face
you should reply to them last two out of
ten just ruined that yeah
yeah you should just like reply back
being like listen honey i've done porn
before
this this this is weird this penis is
weak
and then they'll probably stop doing it
after that maybe
they're going to be haters maybe i mean
who needs it who needs them do you
really want people who send
uncles to dick pics to be your fans do
you want that kind of order
that's the level of simping i don't
wanna be involved with
you're just like geez i wish i had
someone to send my penis to
um uh i i'm curious uh
going off something like that and you
know online i feel like you almost have
no privacy right and the people want to
know everything about you
do you get a lot of people who really
want to find out your personal life
and also i'm also curious as well with
jv how much did they like have a say
over
like what you could do in your free time
like relationships and stuff did they
have any say over that
uh most girls and not just jb actresses
but
parents in general in japan right they
try to hide their relationship status
right it's just they pretend for their
fans yeah
or maybe for them because like if you're
say like you got a girlfriend or you got
a boyfriend then sometimes your
fan base like grows smaller yeah yeah
that happens yeah that's really strange
because i feel like in the
west we don't really do that i mean it
happens on youtube i know i lost a
massive
female audience when it came out about
yeah yeah i did
and and subsequently aki also lost a lot
a large like you guys could see that in
the stat
yeah yeah we saw it in the stats like it
was you know no idea
it's recovered now for the both of us
we're back to like 50 50 male to female
but when we first came out i think
i had like an 80 male ratio and aki had
like an 80
like female ratio right just because i
guess all the sims left
damn we have to find the next target
yeah but i mean it came back
obviously but yeah i i assume it's the
same thing
yeah i think it's very different
especially in the japanese industry
where like they have this obsession with
like keeping a pure image like even more
than west
especially in the idol industry like
that's that's on a level i would never
understand
i mean if if you're allowed to tell us
you don't have to but if it's too
personal it's fine but
how if you did you ever try and date
like after or during the period and like
how was that when you were like not
during it because like you know
it's kind of hard to be like hey i'm
going to work
and i there are a lot of actors like who
are dating
like who are in a relationship but i
didn't know how they coped with it
you know it's a bit like hey yeah hi
honey i'm gonna have sex
and they hate it like dating actors
so they understand the pain of like your
significant other
doing the job right right and some of
them like dated actors too
and like it was always like they were
always fighting because of that
yeah yeah wow so like how small is the
industry do you did you know like a lot
of people
working in the industry like like when
you worked with other actors or
actresses did you already know them
personally or was it something was it
like some someone you met on the day
actors like most i've never got to know
them personally
maybe just on social media they they try
to
i don't think they're nicer
like i don't know not compared to
anybody that's a community
no male actors they want
after like a request they can make a
request like i want this actor
on this set that kind of thing right so
that's why some of them are like
obviously sucking up to you right okay
yeah but in a good way you know
just like me like bringing all those
gifts
you know no no obviously
yeah uh because actors are all
free runs this okay they can get hired
anytime like they don't have management
companies behind you for the guys
you know guys oh wow okay and their
payments are lower
than enough that's how it is i think in
the western yeah because in our mind
like
men are like happy in the industry yeah
okay whereas women sometimes like they
have to do this
yeah right so basically you have you the
all the women have the power to choose
who they want to work with
oh okay so you've got you've got to be
good at socializing and
making network connections if you're a
male porn actress then male 1
actually have to do more like they
usually just
oh i saw you on twitter like you know
they just check
our name and like do some research
before yeah
well we really got to know them yes
it's like real life isn't it yeah if you
want to be associated with someone just
don't be a dick
don't be an [ __ ] and you'll probably
be associated with them yeah
i wanted to know actually and i know
this is like kind of going to get a bit
weird
but like you know how there's a type of
jav and this is only in jav
but it's like the creepy dude right like
like you know we we call we call it the
ugly bastard i think
in other words bastard right i've always
wanted to know
like well first of all have you ever
done anything like that like in that
genre and if you have
like what what are the actors like in
real life because i
i've always wanted to know right because
it's like like 50 year old men looking
yeah yeah and they purposely have to
like act creepy right yeah
just like we actually need them in the
industry
it's not amazing but the directors and
staff members producers say because the
people watching
people can relate to that oh my god
it's true it's true i've always heard
this but i never thought i was like no
that can't be it
people can identify with them easily
big man i mean just like doging like
there are some awesome guys
you know beautiful always beautiful
women yeah of course sometimes
most of it is the ugly guy it's like a
meme in in our circles where
i imagine though did you just get to
that point where you're like you don't
care it's just like work
or or were you like oh god okay i didn't
even hate
any of them yeah i was like i was so
well there must be some days right where
you rock up and you're like oh this
uh yeah i mean i'm good at acting i
guess like he looks way
20 years ago don't lie he definitely
uses the snow app on his head shot
actually guys like who think who lacks
confidence
in their body they're actually nicer to
you like they appreciate you
okay that makes so much sense yeah if i
wasn't an actor
you're giving some people a lot of
confidence right now
that's me i can [ __ ] good
i can be an ugly
like a bastard actor they tend to be
just like [ __ ]
yeah yeah it's just like whatever i can
do
i'm handsome like you're happy with that
right anything
i mean wow to think that the more
handsomer you are the more egotistical
who would have thought to think that
ugly bastards are a
like wanted commodity in the phone
industry oh yeah
one actor i think who been around in the
industry more than 10 years so he's
obviously
our experienced one right yeah and he's
um
good looking now he was like if i do
this then you're going to squirt what
what what
come come come come come no
no no
oh i have to [ __ ] you now you just said
that to me are you serious yeah
like what is like a mariachi band like
yeah
what the [ __ ]
oh my god did you could you imagine if
it was the opposite
if like you're about to like have sex
with a girl and she's like
when i do that oh my god she's all over
me i'm just like
we'll see like i mean i can actually
imagine that with some people though
that's some ideal relationship so that's
the whole dom thing right it's like
they're like oh my god yes
oh my god that that's crazy like to ruin
to ruin the perception i
i gotta ask how much of of uh
adult video is just faked like right
right
it totally depends on the work sometimes
we
think we make a fake camp
yeah yeah do you guys think have you
guys seen the asa banana the product the
drinking product
it's like it's like it's like a banana
flavored jelly yeah yeah yeah
we actually use that for baking squirt
it on you
yeah yes you can insert that
i got to google this yeah because i
remember drinking that
yeah i remember we briefly talked about
this in the interview you were saying
that like a lot of the fake calm
is like the asana stuff but it's also
like milk or like
uh white egg egg white egg whites like
yeah it just gets the consistency right
make sure you don't have any food
allergy
[Laughter]
you turn up to your first porn are you
i need my [ __ ] gluten free thank you very
much
as long as the [ __ ] is grass-fed
i need my starbucks semi-semi skim
if an actor won't come in this scene
then you can still
use the actor in the next scene right
yeah you can save his company you can
save him the energy so
is that is that how hentai protagonists
have like just
so much come every time you know
something
is this why they're like all the dvds
are like three hours long
like they like save it because you when
you do like uh cause they're like
they're really long right like
two hours minimum is that in one day or
is that like a multiple day thing oh
usually just one day because
renting a studio is very expensive so is
it one is it one actor the entire time
uh
it depends on but sometimes they just
change and they make it feel b
so they won't find out sometimes yeah
because i've seen like
i've seen like i've seen like best of
eight hours long and
in my head i'm just like first of all
wow that's a long shoot
second of all who is gonna sit down and
watch eight hours
just give me anxiety trying to find the
the best part right
now like is it made for people with like
erectile dysfunction whereas it's like
it just takes
like give me two hours and i'll be there
like yeah i just i just don't understand
like
i know they seem to get the longer the
better the longer the better yeah
wow that's like a youtube video i need
to get those mood rolls
i i wonder did you like ever watch any
of your own work or did you just like
when you did it you're like i'm not i'm
not doing anything right
i mean during my career like i did watch
some of my crips uh just for studying
for research
is it weird is it weird watching
yourself like at first i was it was so
embarrassing
the light doesn't really hit well
it's all wrong it's okay this angle
isn't for me
i love how you say that you watch during
clips for research but yeah that's the
perfect word
good look better that makes yeah
i mean i i'm sure like we do that right
on on youtube
we sometimes watch back on our old
videos i cringe like i i can't watch
myself on camera like
sometimes even on the podcast i'm i'm
just cringing i used to not be able to
and i think as you like get used to it
more yeah
sometimes you're like damn that was a
good video i love watching this hat on
the back yeah
man like god damn i like job me i look
down good
funny joke comes up and you're like damn
that was a good joke
you never ever like that when you're
watching you're like oh i remember this
part yeah
sometimes i just laughed with those like
dirty words i just said
that line was from this manga
i personally go old 2d when it comes to
like when you are reduce yourself
i never watch porn you know yeah i go
for 2d all the time
wait before you ever like got into porn
did you never watch like
research i was curious like how they
make
the video yeah that's why i wanted to
get in but i wasn't
i've never been a fan so yeah oh wow
this seems like a lot of steps to just
watch porn
well now i'm curious now like what kind
of like what titles did you read to like
learn the language learn the way longer
recommendations
okay when i it depends on the role i'm
playing
yeah you know sometimes i'm in cabin
attendant you know right
so i just pick all those doji that about
you know flight attendants and they pick
up all those lines
about everything if it exists
and you know yeah very common yeah
i just pick up some lines from each and
every
did you know everyone did this or was it
or was this just you mean
how did other people learn how to like
do it maybe maybe that was porn maybe
yeah i don't know
i mean i like to make jokes you know
yeah yeah
i don't know there was one thing you
know
if you're in a car now scroll spray like
you have a needle like i'm going to put
you know what you say yeah yeah yeah put
a needle on you like yo you got a huge
needle like you know
kind of injection or whatever like do
you try to like
play with words like i of course like i
said it in japanese so yeah
it's kind of hard to transfer yeah yeah
yeah yeah if you're right attendant like
you know have a nice fries and like oh
it's fries i think
eating that sperm had a great fried or
something like that
saying like you're coming but more like
you're taking off
that kind of thing you know did you ever
like burst out laughing or couldn't keep
a straight face while you
the director is sad like ask me not to
do that
man who knew that your real career was
in comedy all along
it's not so much you losing it's just
like all the stuff it's just like a good
one
oh my god that's hilarious i like the
word praises
yeah yeah yeah actually going off in
hentai you mentioned in joey's interview
last time that you were working you were
voice acting in a hentai soon
i was very curious one if you can talk
about it now and two what the entire
process is like
i assume it's not the low budget aero
games that these two are playing when
they're
growing hey man don't don't get it yeah
we want to know more about this
hentai voice actor however the
production has been delayed because of
kobe 19.
also supposed to come out like sometime
soon we
haven't filmed yet i had an audition and
like i got a role
but we cannot film yet because it
increased a lot of mourning and
[Laughter]
i imagine like you going into that
audition was like saitama going into
like a kids boxing tour
like it was just like oh yeah this is
easy this is easy mode it was so
difficult at first because like there
are pictures already
there right that's the difference
between normal anime and hentai anime
because
i mean they got all the pictures ready
for you but normal like a regular anime
they haven't it's just a rough image
yeah yeah yeah
speak however you want like within this
amount of time so the hentai is like
fully colored yeah you have to like
you know match oh wow so all hentai is
actually
dubbed hentai so you have to match like
the moans and everything with what's
going on
that was hard i feel that hentai voice
actors have it
so much like harder than regular voice
actors because like
especially if like you're female because
there are some scenes that i'm just like
damn this must be like totally on their
throat
and you cannot get too into it because
like the next scene it could be like
something that could be the biggest no
okay it could be an even bigger one you
know i mean i
just i don't i wouldn't know i don't
watch any any bad things oh yeah
of i think we can all agree that
like it'd be cool if we could like voice
acting i would love to voice that would
be great
just for the experience alone right like
my audience will never let
like me go for it yeah but like they'll
probably never take me seriously ever
again but
i've watched in a yowie where i did a
sex scene oh no i i i haven't had anyone
bring that up to me much
yeah but that's because you're 93
percent yeah that's very true i made my
own no one would hire me to do hentai so
i was like [ __ ] it
i'm going to make my own i'm going to
i just moaned nice audio book yeah
you get to hear it like surround sound
six inch surround sound
corner did you ever shout come like
seven times
now no but you know like
when i was voicing it right you would
you would do it and you're like i'm
already getting pretty loud and then
like you said like you turn the page
you're like i've gotta get louder than
this
like this is the climax like how do you
like i mean i've never had experience
having to like screech
like coming at the top of my lungs
before but he was in the manga so i had
to replicate that and i'm like
it's a very strange process because it's
so hard to fake
come that loud because in real life i
would never shout when coming
yeah because in real life you'd just be
like and also i don't want to disturb my
downstairs neighbors they're very
very elderly right i don't wanna
yeah my voice already travels through
walls yeah yeah yeah
it's like the low vibrations that travel
through the walls yeah yeah i think i
haven't
did i tell you this guy's like when my
all of my old houses the walls were so
thin that my voice had like the same
natural frequency
as the rules so when i spoke they would
always vibrate
your voice can not show like it's
naturally
resonates like everywhere yeah we've had
comments every now and then on the
podcast where people are just like i
actually can't understand what
conversation it's going like
sometimes it just sounds like mumbles
it's so deep it just sounds like whoa
like just like a sub woof you know yeah
yeah you can get
lost
i i i remember it was so weird because
when my voice broke
i was like 13 when i started to sound
like oh right could you imagine like
what did you sound like before very high
pitched really it's always those ways
because i've seen some clips of
like the official movie trailer voices
and how they got their voice and
apparently
every one of them had really really high
voices and then it just
dropped like that one people thought i
was messing around
like they thought i was joking because i
used to do voices like all the time like
oh my god
you know like way higher though used to
like do dumb voices
so when i came into school and my voice
started like getting like
yo yo whatever like people were like
what the
[ __ ] is faking this i was like no no i
don't know what happened i think it's a
sore throat or something but i'm gonna
be fine
a week later i still have it and i'm
like what the hell so wait did it just
happen like overnight or
i think it happened over like a week or
two right
i don't know is that is that how it
happens i have no idea how it happened i
think mine just dropped
immediately i think it's just like it's
like a snap do you remember
i don't remember now that i think about
it no you get well because
you listen to your voice every day right
so like the subtle difference is you
can't hear it
yeah so you're just like oh [ __ ] i guess
my voice is here now like i didn't
realize that i used to like scare the
youngest kids in the hallway i would
walk behind them and i'd be like yo yo
what up
yo and they were
so you've done like so much in your
career right like you've done jv you've
done journalism you're now doing cosplay
you're doing you know you're writing a
book and everything like crazy
what's the next step for you like like
you you seem like you always want to be
like challenging
yeah yeah yeah which is like we we can
all get behind that right we all love
trying new stuff so like coming from
someone who
seemingly looks like they've done
everything like what's the next step
that you want to do
i've just started streaming on twitch
because of kron team because like
yeah i don't have nowhere to go like i i
love staying in but
i love to go visit western cons of
course that's not gonna happen
at least until yeah until next year
probably
yeah what what is your twitch by the way
just said oh
so you shout it out maybe he's gonna sit
right here
in the link down below she knows the
editor will do it
yeah yeah i watched some of your streams
before
and they were really good i mean you
spoke you speaking japanese and english
on the street yeah
in english yeah the language telling
english because that's a good practice
for me
and i love going to cons
and overseas because in japan like i'm
already again like a jb actress
and there are a lot of cosplayers who
are not like on
that like risque level yeah yeah yeah
some japanese chronic don't want to
touch that area like that's just too
that's no private foreign
if you grab your idol it's fine
being
if you wear pc like if you haven't seen
areola and that's fine but
yeah if you've seen everything already
then that's like no no
yeah yeah yeah so there is no room for
me to
be there right i guess like i'm not
going to be needed there
and like i love speaking english i love
learning more
so and i love how otaku how weep
like how real we
was so impressed by every single one of
they are so open-minded about
every single genre too yeah because
there are a lot of people like a lot of
otakus in japan webs in japan
who just focus on one genre
oh i don't watch the show and don't even
dare to ask like what the show is about
or like let me show the interest like
yeah yeah
oh i never watched ever and that's it
like this that's the end of the
conversation like
maybe you can ask me yeah as we always
but i love her though i went to the boys
love section in a manga store here and i
got so many looks
all the women were like what the [ __ ] is
it yeah i get that too every time anki
like wants to go buy like kingdom hearts
i'm just like i i shouldn't be here i'm
getting really weird
like i'm not welcome like i'm yeah i'm
in danger here i i sometimes get that
just from walking down like ultimate
road in ikebukuro
because like you know otomero obviously
as the name implies like it's for like
fujioshi's and just like
girls who are into that kind of stuff
yeah and i'm just like i'm just get off
this public
and and there are just like some i i
legit get stares from like some
other like fujioshi's who are just like
you don't belong here
what are you doing here you're a man you
cis white male he's a
male he's amazing enjoying my gay porn
yeah
get out of here i'm just like it's a
public road there's no males allowed in
gay porn
no no no you actually went to the
uh the yowie cafe right the boys love
cafe i actually sat
exactly same thing
you dm me say i'm going to like tomorrow
how was it did you enjoy it
it was interesting they were all wearing
masks
so if you if you don't know i mean i
might as well plug my own video go and
watch the the yowie cafe video it's
great
it's where they basically do they really
rush like everything
whole throughout the whole episode again
yeah i was like
you're so red because it's like okay
basically they pretty much
act bl scenes in front of you yeah i
haven't but i
watched these videos like it's as like a
western person it like doesn't like work
in my brain yeah
this thing is so like i mean i had to i
had to translate some of the like
in aki's video because they're doing it
in japanese yeah and aki's like i don't
know what they're saying so can you
translate this
and just sitting there and just watching
like the video of your skits i'm just
like
oh no yeah i watched an ackee's video
too right yeah i'm just like oh my god i
can't i can't
we turned up but they were like so what
do you want us to do and i'm like like
just do your thing
what do you normally do just like just
just do it just do it we'll blur it out
like just do it
and they just feel like oh we can do
like a rice thing and i'm like sure and
they start doing it and i'm like oh my
god like they're doing this
and i feel so bad for you because you
know aggie was with her female friends
so like
right so they were all just by yourself
and the worst part was
that they would do and they're like are
you happy
[Applause]
and then they did the thing where
they're like what's the thing where you
put your arms yeah
and then i was like and they did that
and i'm like yeah this is cool and all
but uh can you like can one of you hold
my kermit the doll
like kermit the frog i brought my kermit
the frog with me
and i was like i was like hey maybe
because you like it's like you know
it's a little joke on my channel like
hey maybe could you do something the guy
just [ __ ] grabs it
shoves his hand inside kermit and it's
like we're gonna do a scene with kermit
i didn't even get to say anything he's
[ __ ] laser beamed onto this curve
like finally something i can fist
we'll do a scene with it and i'm like
dying i'm like oh my god this is so
embarrassing
because like there's like two cameras on
me everyone's like is this what you
wanted connor just you this is the
footage you wanted i'm like
i guess this is what i wanted like oh my
god one of the hardest videos to sit
through there's just something about
seeing you know real people acting like
like anime characters you know in anime
you know it's it's like it just seems
normal but when you see
real live people doing it sometimes
going to a maid cafe is just like
don't talk about me caffeine i i went
once and once was all i needed
which which one i went to uh
it was the one in akiba at home
why are you familiar with them who
and female yeah i went i went to at home
in uh
queen potential yeah yeah because my
friend who's like a huge fan of maid
cafes was like you've never been to a
maid cafe
we should go it's like i know the best
one i'm like all right and i went
and uh man i've i've never been more
disappointed in a two thousand yen
omurice in my life
i'm just like this thing cost 2 000 yen
and it took like
45 minutes to come out and it's like
cold
and they put the spell on it right yeah
and they put a spell on it and i'm like
you could yeah they did they do like the
muay morikun spell and they they force
you to say it as well
i don't need a spell i need a microwave
spell isn't doing anything but making it
cold
the most awkward experience in my life
was having to do that
i was dressed as a maid and i had to
identify at the airport yeah
um and there was like 10 businessmen
and they were like they were all just
just not saying anything not not
laughing
whenever i did anything they were just
staring and it was horrible because
these girls were really awkward as mates
like yeah
supposed to be like wow but they were
like
and then i had to draw on the omu rice i
drew sanic
[Laughter]
with ketchup yeah with ketchup and it
was like diffusing a bomb it was so
tense in that room everyone everyone was
silent while i was doing it
and i'm like sweating yeah i'm like yeah
i'm like can we can someone break the
silence do something funny
whenever i made a joke obviously because
none of them could speak english they
were just like
just just to break the silence you
should just like under your breasts just
being like dude
so you like made cafes uh my friend that
made cafe so i
i don't go there by myself no i'm not an
avid like
yeah yeah because there are some
religious people yeah there's people
that go to every maid cafe and just rate
every maid cafe
like this oh this maid was pretty cute
oh she said mo mo kun
the way i wanted to play it the way i
wanted to hear it
you know there's a i saw a guy and he's
he's a guy in japan who has reviewed
every starbucks in japan
oh my god every single starbucks in
japan i think he's reviewed and there's
like
japanese japanese guy like 10 i think
there's 10 plus 10
000. jesus christ i think of something
to all of them oh nearly all of them i
think he's working his way through i
mean
he's still going but he's done like over
half i know how different could they be
yeah that's what i think i'm like you
picked like the worst coffee chain
is that about customer service thing or
i don't know
like i understand if like he went around
to like go to like every like
independently owned
coffee shop right because like there's
little differences but
i'm pretty sure a starbucks in hokkaido
is going to be the same starbucks as an
okinawa right
maybe he cares about the what the cup
says like
with the doodle i'm gonna go to hokkaido
yeah yeah um so i noticed that you're a
huge fan of retro games
oh yeah and i i think we all grew up
these retro games
um i mean could you tell us some of your
favorite retro games i'm interested
or is that too old the one i played most
was
sailor moon action game really it's very
very
final fight-ish but is that the fighting
game
no it's actually action game so like you
get it's exactly like final fight you
just keep walking and some
are like like double dragon yeah yeah we
call in japanese the belt action
build score action game right keep going
yeah i think uh i think my cousin like
had like a collection because there was
a number of them right there was like
six or seven of them on the uh
at least two funny game for action games
and one puzzle game
one rpg two fighting games
i don't know which game was even galleon
game you were streaming oh yeah
ever i played the first
playstation ever game i gave a game for
playstation right it was generation game
so you think like you choose a sudden
no answer and that's going to change the
ending yeah but actually
until the very end nothing doesn't it's
always the same
until the very end this final question
gonna let you choose three paths like
three endings right
nothing but everything else so it's
basically it was basically just mass
effect then
your choices mean nothing you can't even
skip
any stories you have to re-watch it
again and again that is like conan's
worst nightmare that's my hell
i love like i love the old neo geo games
like metal slug is like my favorite
series
i recently just did a video where i went
and uh played a bunch of like
japan only retro games like anime retro
games um
like uh there was the because there's
like a number of like jojo games as well
like
uh super famicom and like i know you
should have show games
dude but i didn't realize that it's a
really popular game
in japan but no one in the west knows
about it because
they only localized it well obviously
they're only released in japan
and for some reason brazil but only
brazil
like the us didn't get it europe didn't
get it australia didn't get it it was
only brazil that goddess
there are maybe a lot of like japanese
brazilians at the time oh yeah there is
a i i found this out today actually
because the
professional wrestler like a legendary
professional wrestler
oh yeah yeah that makes sense that's
right yeah yeah yeah that's right yeah
apparently there is a huge
uh population of japanese in brazil i
can't remember the reason why but uh
anime is like pretty big in brazil so
i've heard i mean way bigger than it was
you know where where we grew up but it's
just it just amazes me how many anime
games there are that have just existed
that would just
never get translated yeah yeah even some
big ones still have not been translated
why because the sierra moon rpg one they
just got fans out a few years ago
yeah yeah after all those years the
original
face daylight visual novel has still not
been officially translated
really yeah yeah so you if anyone who's
played the original face day night
vision novel it's it's all fan
translations right now
and fake fans expect people to get
people into it by reading the visual
novel yeah because i know it was like
really massive news i think it was like
three years ago
when uh they decided to make an official
uh like english translation of the clan
ad visual novel and they made like a
kickstarter for it and everything and it
got finished in like less than 24 hours
even though it's such an old game and
and it wasn't at that point i realized
i'm like oh [ __ ] there's never been an
official translation of this game
it's all fan sobs and in my head i'm
just like who is doing these fan stuff
it's like who has so much time like you
can talent
that you're like you know what there's
this visual novel that's all dialogue
200 plus hours long it's probably like
if you've put into a script it's like
you know 300 400 pages
yeah i'm a translator like like how do
you get
how do you find yourself in that
position weebs weaponized man
weaves are so passionate they are yeah
they are like what's uh was it was it
secret of manner that never got an
official
the first one yeah yeah yeah final
fantasy never got released even though
it was a huge series
until very recently yeah it's all very
racist which is crazy to think a game
series like final fantasy that was
killing it in the west as well like
one of them wasn't released yeah yeah
that's crazy it's really weird
i have a lot of macros fanatic friends
in california especially
but i think the only official one was
robotech right
yeah yeah yeah yeah i don't wanna you
have to look for them yeah
fishery it's hard being a weeb man oh
it's hard especially a
retro weeb because now like macross or
macros sorry is like it's it's not
got as big of a fan base as it used to
because now mecca has just kind of like
almost died in the like the western
fandom it's
only the very dedicated fans that still
will keep up with
everything like that and if there is
mecca then it's usually combined with
some other genre
that is more appealing right yeah it's
like it's it's not usually like mecca is
the main it's like
here is the main and we just add a
little bit of mecca to it i think like
the last big mecca was probably darling
in the franxx and i'm pretty sure
more people cared about zero two than
they cared about the mex
no one was like oh darling in the franks
those meccas are cool
like darling in the franks it was the
side of the mechanic
like damn that booty's thick yeah that's
all i cared about
dude we missed out on so many good porn
parodies japan because you're dumb laws
of darwin and the franchise yeah oh my
god
i'm surprised they haven't made a
darling in the frank's pawn yet or in
fact
so many anime series or manga series
that could easily
make a porn parody and i know it will
sell
right all right well american porn
producers who listen to trash taste
please make it happen
hey man we just gave you guys like free
real estate yeah exactly right
because you know people are going to buy
that [ __ ] if they make it in the west
right
yeah yeah macros for example like my
friend actually organized
a macroscope macros convention
oh wow oh wow it's called super
dimension kong
so that's amazing that even though we
didn't have an access
to the official one yeah yeah yeah and
also
i've noticed that there are a lot of
consumer fans in the west because i play
consumer
it's huge it's huge yeah yeah and every
single time
at least one person or i should say at
least 10 people
again asking me every single time when
it's gonna be released like you know
yeah yeah in the west uh internationally
i mean i know people like
creators but they said
they're only making available for macau
hong kong taiwan within this year i'm
not thinking about english translation
yet
yeah yeah it's it's weird right like
they they
tend to really focus on southeast asian
countries it's because we spend the
[ __ ]
cash what can i say
yeah that's that's what i like because i
remember i i guessed it at a
con in singapore right and uh and there
were like all sorts of different booths
with like all these companies were like
selling new stuff like new merch and
everything yeah yeah and at an american
con right
it's like only the die hard fans would
like to go up and like be like
give me one of everything right yeah
like you know give me the most expensive
thing
yeah and it was just nuts to see so many
people
just being like give me this give me
this give me this i'm just like and
people
having like you know five six bags worth
of stuff and i'm just like
jesus christ like how much money do you
have because the tickets aren't cheap
either
i think it's just the culture there that
they just want to collect them all and
collect
everything so i mean combining that with
gacha
i mean that's the money printing machine
right yeah right and like
it was really funny as well because i
did a signing at that singapore
convention
and uh and and the first guy like came
up to my table there was like a line and
the first guy came up to my table and
was like
so how much is uh for a signature
and i was like what do you mean he's
like how much like you know we we pay
like a signing
signing fee right like because i want to
get this signed by you like how much is
it
and i'm just like i did nothing i'll
just sign it for you
and they just didn't understand like
even the staff members were like
what what no [ __ ] for free it's like
it's for free
it's like but is it only is like the
first one
and then the second one i have to build
like no if you i'll i'll sign like
seven things if you want me he's like
what's the catch there must be a cash
there must be a catch right it's like no
just oh they like relay to the president
like no listen he said he was going to
do it
we've never had this before yeah and
apparently
like i asked like the staff members
afterwards but apparently i'm the first
guest at that con
ever who did a free signing what and i'm
just like how willing
are people to pay for things like this
i'm like i get it if it's like you know
a really famous like artist or a
cosplayer yeah like
a lot of their revenue comes from things
right but i'm like
i already make enough money like just
doing my regular job i don't need to
take
[ __ ] five dollars from someone just
to get a little squiggle from me like on
a piece of paper right it's like it's
fine i'll just do it for free
because the thing is is that i was
already signing people
stuff before my signing like if people
just found me
and were like hey can you sign this i'm
like yeah of course like like
i don't think my school's worth that
much man yeah it's like no it's not it's
not worth that much i came up with the
signature in like
two seconds like it's like i don't know
it's not it's not that valuable yours is
like semi-decent mine's badly legible
i just write c like something i don't
want to think of something
yeah one's like a child squiggles man
it's just that way
yeah but yeah it's just nuts how like
southeast asian
weebs are just a they're all [ __ ]
rich
yeah like you're so sorry stop spending
money so that game companies care about
their speakers or maybe western people
have to spend more yeah
the thing is i don't think they're rich
i just think that this is what they
spend
all their like income population as well
yeah
there's a larger audience for you
unfortunately i mean not unfortunately
it's great for the game company hey so
western weaves if you want your game to
be localized
you better spend start spending some
money go grab your mom's credit card
right rise up gamers we need to
release and grind gamers yeah because
there's like so many gacha games here
that would just never get translated
there's like
three jojo gacha games or something like
that they're pretty awful
translated no no no even jojo
yeah just because the west like just
gotcha games in general in the west are
like
i think it's like only really like a
recent thing that it's like oh yeah cool
i could spend money on these but it's a
new thing because the
whole image of mobile games in the west
was like
very terrible you know everyone thinks
of like this you know
cheap knockoff games or like rage shadow
legends like angry birds
yeah candy crush and it's like i'm not
spending two dollars to get an extra
life on candy crush i'm sorry i'm not
that desperate
yeah the the for a very long time all
mobile games are pretty like
um predatory i'd say yeah yeah and how
they try to make you spend money
right so i think there is that kind of
notion of mobile game equals you're
trying to scam me
yeah so maybe there is a lot of that but
hopefully it'll change in future and
we'll finally get that
super localization yeah cause that game
looks fun yeah yeah it does
i mean i enjoy konosuba dojin a lot too
i don't usually go for dojin like
i don't really go for it woman of
culture yeah dojin adaptation i always
go for
jazz stories who's the who's the
favorite
[Laughter]
i mean she can purify any liquid
so any happiness happens
you know she can just purify you like
damn i wish i had that when i was doing
it
[ __ ] none of this banana drink [ __ ] none
of this gluten-free [ __ ]
on my hair only the purest of jizz i'm a
darkness man
i love darkness yeah darkness
here we [ __ ]
i can see just that one clip being gift
and just like really spread around
now hi chris hanson
so as is tradition with uh trash taste
episodes that have guests we're going to
get you to sign
yay so that we may uh put it up on this
wall right here we say that
but chris's one is still down
this is his right hand i love you guys
it's fishery
that's a signature that's a signature
look at that squiggle god damn but yeah
thank you very much for coming on it's
been a pleasure to have you have a guest
in the meantime uh here are all the
lovely patrons who are here uh
supporting the trash taste
uh channel we definitely know that this
episode is gonna be demonetized as [ __ ]
so look at these guys
thank you very much yeah yeah on this
one so if you like to support the show
and uh hopefully get some more cool
guests onto this show then uh definitely
yes support our patreon and uh
[ __ ] i don't know what to say please
support
patreon yeah yeah we just started you
ever just start a sentence and you don't
know where it's going to lead but you
just have to keep talking anyway
that's the one do you want to like shout
anything out
oh no please follow me on social media
twitter
instagram uh also on twitch it's very
new
um my youtube channel isn't my personal
channel i'm just hired
to be on the channel so i have nothing
to do with editing so stop telling me to
good english
i will leave all of those down in the
description below so definitely go check
it out and uh
thank you so much for joining us thank
you i hope you had a good time here
yeah all right but yeah anyway that's
been trash taste podcast
um i've been here with the boys and the
girl
it's nice to not have to be in a sausage
fresh with a podcast for once
and yeah we will see you guys later bye
are you saying that now see you later
see you later see you later i'll see you
[Music]
later
[Music]
you